Vic d'or, bonsoir. [rires]
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle
Sinkerview. Nous sommes en direct.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Alors, je m'appelle Vic de Rassau,
je fais 1,6
et en ce moment, je dois peser 65 kg.
Voilà. Ah
ça une présentation courte, c'est bien
succintement respect. C'est la carte
Panini.
C'est vrai.
Ouais. Les
Bon, on va parler de foot, on va parler
géopolitique du foot, économie, on va
peut-être parler un peu d'actualité avec
le foot, avec ce qui s'est passé un peu
aujourd'hui et dans les semaines
précédentes. Euh si on parlait évasion
fiscale, hm
est-ce que tu as déjà fait de l'évasion
fis ? Pardon, j'ai dit tu
Ou ouais. Alors euh Non, non, non,
jamais jamais jamais. Ça me traverse
même pas l'esprit. récemment, c'est
marrant, il y a il y a un un mec alors
sur la fiscalité, même pas l'évasion
fiscale. Euh j'ai j'étais jeune à 20
ans, euh
le conseiller que j'avais rencontré, il
m'a il m'a il m'a dit euh il y a les
lois euh Ponce, je crois, euh tu places
de l'argent dans dans les domes. Ouais.
tu mets, tu achètes des bateaux de
pêche, je sais pas quoi et euh voilà,
c'est c'est la loi et tu défiscalises et
euh les bateaux de pêche ont coul je
pense et j'ai tout perdu et je moi je
découvrais l'argent et je je savais que
moi je j'étais pas comme ça que ça
m'intéressait pas de de enfin tu vois la
première fois je payais les impôts. Je
pense que mes parents n'ont jamais payé
d'impôts.
Comment comment ça se passe ?
Il est plus jamais refait.
le fait qu'il y ait des footballeurs qui
cherchent à optimiser à tout prix alors
qu'il gagnent des millions et des
millions et que
alors franchement alors je sais je sais
pas
s'ils le font combien
c'est pas eux qui sont dangereux pour la
planète he je veux dire il y en a qui
défiscalisent
qui sont méchants. Nous les
footballeurs, je dire on est une petite
niche, on est peu de on est très peu à
gagner beaucoup d'argent. enfin ceux qui
gagnent beaucoup d'argent. Euh et donc
dans CL, il y en a quelques-uns qui vont
essayer de tricher. Et par rapport à ces
grands groupe, grands patrons et cetera
qui défiscalise des milliards,
franchement on n'est pas dangereux, on
fait rien de mal puis on essaie de faire
croire que nous c'est pas bien. C'est
pas bien. Il faut le combattre et puis
aller les chercher comme les autres.
Mais c'est c'est les autres qu'il faut
aller chercher. Et puis
c'est qui les autres ? Bah les grands
groupes, le CAC 40 les milliardaires euh
voilà ce qui les cusac.
Ouais. Ouais. Évidemment al plus quand
c'est des politiques. Tu imagines ?
Alors lui cusac c'était c'était quand
même un génie quand même. C'est un mec
qui était là pour lutter contre les
évasions fiscales qui avait un un compte
en Suisse. C'est marrant parce que
récemment l'impôt c'est quelque chose de
très très important euh pour moi. Euh il
y a un mec qui m'a dit "Je croise dans
la rue", il me dit "Monsieur Dasso, je
vous adore et tout." J'étais super
content et tout.
Je voudrais vous parler d'un truc. Euh
je dis bah dites faut qu'on se revoit.
Je dis mais non dites-moi tout de suite
et tout. Euh je je rends les gens
heureux. Ah je lui dit bah oui, je veux
savoir là. Dites-moi dites-moi. Genre je
croyais qu'il allait me parler de yoga
de je sais pas moi de trucs spirituel et
il me dit voilà vous au lieu de payer
votre impôt vous le prenez et vous le
placez quelque part comme ça ça vous
rapporte de l'argent. Je dis bah non,
moi je fais pas ça monsieur, ça
m'intéresse pas et tout ça. C'était
marrant comme comme pour lui
être heureux c'était gagner de l'argent,
un peu tricher, voler.
Il se rendait pas compte que moi ça me
rend pas heureux. Peut-être que lui ça
le rend heureux et que c'est c'est pas
non plus avec l'argent. Peut-être que
l'argent heureux et que si et puis
surtout l'homme que je suis valide pas
ce genre de de choses.
Les football le l
Ouais. Les footballistes comme les les
lanceurs d'alerte là qui qui qui
dénoncent qui sont importants. Dans les
footbal, il y a eu pas mal de choses,
notamment sur le racisme, il y a pas eu
que
que l'argent. Il y a eu aussi les petits
jeunes, comment ils étaient formés par
exemple aussi. comment on décidait de
former des des Alors ça, j'ai découvert
quelque chose. J'ai toujours cru que le
talent était très important et que le
foot était incontestable. Si tu es bon,
tu joueras. Et ben avec ce Football X,
j'ai compris que non, on pouvait aussi
former un blanc ou un noir. On pouvait
décider qui allait devenir
professionnel. et que euh j'ai j'ai
j'étais jeune euh mes copains musulmans
ont subi Moi aussi évidemment euh les
noirs subissaient le racist blanc hein.
Ouais ouais mes copains rebeux musulmans
parce que je me souviens du Ramadan où
l'entraîneur était pas cool, il forçait
à bouffer, il forçait à bouffer du porc
et euh et moi j'étais fort et je me
disais bah quand et mes potes qui
étaient forts, plus forts que les
autres, bah là la couleur peut pas les
arrêter. Et ben avec ce truc de football
X, je me suis rendu compte que non.
Parce que si l'entraîneur, il décide de
te faire jouer toi, même si tu es moins
bon, s'il décide de te former plus, de
t'entraîner plus, il peut le faire.
C'était c'est ça m'a surpris. Donc il y
a du racisme même dans la formation.
C'est ce que m'ont appris.
On va revenir sur les questions de
racisme un peu plus tard.
Mais les lanceurs d'ê, c'est important.
Football X, Wikileak et cetera sont très
importants.
L'attribution de la Coupe du monde au
Qatar. Il y a des bigouilles un peu
là-dedans ?
La FIFA c'est c'est un je pense
l'organisme le plus un des organismes
les plus corrompus
du monde qui j'imagine aussi là pour le
coup fait beaucoup d'évasion fiscale.
Voilà la FIFA a interdit
l'ingérence politique dans ses
magouilles. Donc il a il traite
directement avec les fédérations. Macron
récemment a voulu intervenir, on lui a
dit non, tu as pas le droit. Euh c'est
quand même ça veut quand même dire euh
techniquement laissez-nous faire ce
qu'on veut et notamment avec le pognon.
Et euh évidemment euh euh sur euh sur
les attributions, on voit bien que il y
a il y a rien de de d'angélique, de
beau, de euh on va chercher des marchés,
on va chercher de l'argent, on va on va
mais on il y a pas d'intérêt général, il
y a pas le football c'est normalement
quelque chose qui est tourné vers le
lien social, le vivre ensemble et par et
eux ils font du business.
Euh récemment, la la FIFA c'est un truc
incroyable. C'est quand même une
organisation
euh qui fait travailler des gens
gratuitement et qui s'enrichit
gratuitement. Neymar, il va jouer la
Coupe du monde avec le Brésil
gratuitement pour la FIFA qui prend tout
le pognon. La FIFA n'a pas
de continent, n'a pas le monde déjà, n'a
pas de continent, n'a pas de pays, n'a
pas de ville, n'a pas de stade, n'a pas
de public. Elle a rien et c'est elle qui
fait l'argent parce qu'elle organise le
football et elle impose aux États sa
loi. C'est un truc de fou. Et en plusut,
il y a plus de monde à la FIFA, je crois
qu'à l'ONU. Je crois que la FIFA peut
mettre un un pays à terre, lui imposer
quelque chose au risque de sortir de la
FIFA. Et et c'est là qu'il faut
s'organiser parce que les footballeurs
comme
Neymar, Messi et cetera, il c'est eux
qui ont le pouvoir. C'est toujours le
rapport de force des classes.
C'est je trouve ça incroyable.
Voilà la FIFA. Euh Fontino récemment, il
a été c'est par acclamation, je sais pas
si si tu savais ça, il a été réélu par
acclamation. Donc ses copains, ils
arrivent hop super. Donc euh là, ils
viennent de dire que euh en fait donc
ils mettent la le Var et puis après ils
trouvent ça super entre eux.
Ils disent que ce qu'ils ont fait est
super.
Est-ce que tu pourrais dire que c'est
[soupir][souffle coupé]
comme une mafia ?
Oui, puis c'est le libéralisme,
nolibéraliste, je sais pas trop comment
on appelle tout ça. De nouveau
l'exploitation.
Alors, le footballeur est un un un
employé, un salarié, je sais pas trop,
un peu particulier, notamment ceux qui
jouent pour la FIFA parce qu'il est très
très bien payé. il est privilégié, il
est célèbre, mais il est au service de
d'une organisation euh qui s'en met
plein les poches et qui
c'est quoi plein poche ?
Bah, j'en sais rien. Je crois que
c'était 2 milliards 2 milliards de
résultats net le il y a quelques années
récemment ça doit être un peu plus. il
ils vont chercher des marchés comme je
réfléchissais ça à ça l'autre fois euh
l'UEFA, la FIFA, le foot, le foot
français, la ligue euh Conforama
aujourd'hui elle s'appelle euh je me
disais mais en fait il y avait un
joueur, c'était Schneider qui partait à
la retraite. Il y a quand même moins de
joueurs qui partent à la retraite que de
joueurs qui qui sortent qu'il faut qu'il
joue à un moment. Donc on va chercher
des marchés et on développe le foot
ailleurs et comme ça il y a de plus en
plus de de clubs de de joueurs qui
peuvent jouer et ça ça crée encore plus
de précarité évidemment avec aussi des
différences entre les très très riches
joueurs et les
Platini il s'est fait un peu inquiéter
avec toutes ces histoires.
Ça ça t'a pas fait mal de voir un grand
champion comme ça ?
Ouais. Et il y a un truc que je que qui
est incroyable, c'est euh c'est alors
Platini, il doit pas être euh
tout blanc. B
Justice le dira.
Mais bien sûr. Ouais. Et et pour arriver
à ce genre de poste, il faut euh
magouiller, voilà, être une anguille et
cetera. Mais ce qui est exceptionnel
quand même, c'est quand même un joueur
de football
qui est devenu président d'une grande
instance mondiale européenne. Là pour le
coup, ça arrive nulle part dans aucune
instance à travers le monde, que ce soit
euh économique, politique, tout ce que
tu veux, ça arrive pas quoi. Le
footballeur, il joue au foot à part le
Bayern de Munich peut-être où les
présidents, ils deviennent ils sont ils
sont des anciens joueurs. Et il y a il y
a ça quand même qui est quelque chose
qu'il faut
soulever et reconnaître et qui je me
souviens Lilian Turam il avait intégré
alors le comité exécutif, je sais pas
trop ce que c'était à l'époque dans les
années 2010 une sorte de comité. Il est
parti quoi, il est pas resté. Moi quand
il est arrivé, je me suis génial quoi.
Lilian Turam qui est là, c'est génial
pour nous. il va nous représenter nous
les joueurs au milieu de de ces
instituts qui s'organisent entre elles
où c'est où c'est le système est est
vraiment bien verrouillé pour que entre
potes il se retrouvent à la tête, il
montent les échelons et à 114 ans, ils
deviennent présidents de la Fédération
française de foot euh et ils sont
président de ligue à 74 après 94 112.
Tu as vu tu as vu passer des mallettes
de billets, des rétrocommissions, des
choses comme ça ? On t'a jamais proposé
des des choses un peu chelou ?
Oui oui, on m'a proposé des choses
cheloues mais c'était pas très
intéressant.
Bah par exemple euh mon tu sais quand
j'ai quand quand je viens des années 70,
je suis formé dans les années 80 euh je
deviens pro dans les années 90 et à 22
23 ans, un mec appelle chez moi, donc
pas de portable sur le fix et il me dit
"Je suis un impressario." Je dis "Mais
c'est quoi un impressario ? Je suis
agent de joueur. Et donc là, je commence
à comme je jouais bien, plein d'agents
m'appellent pour me récupérer et un
agent, un jour mon père m'appelle me dit
"Oui, il m'a proposé 300000 francs pour
que tu signes avec lui, donc tu ne
signeras pas avec lui." Alors, j'ai
découvert que mon père est un enfin j'ai
pas découvert, je le savais. Mon père
est un homme formidable. Il est il est
il est décédé. Euh voilà, j'ai j'ai une
famille formidable qui dans ce milieu-là
a vraiment été incroyable. Mon frère a
été incroyable. Il
t'a protégé. Ouais, puis c'était je mon
père il a refusé 300000 boules quoi.
C'est je suis son fils quoi.
Qui se crevait le cul dans les
chantillag sûr bien sûr il aurait pu ne
pas me le dire et et puis voilà, j'ai
découvert que les agents étaient des des
gens euh
peut-être verreux. Voilà. Voilà.
[grognement]
Moi après j'ai eu un agent qui s'appelle
Mig Gasso que j'ai toujours eu, j'ai eu
début à la fin qui a été aussi l'agent
de Zidane qui est toujours l'agent de
Zidane qui a été l'agent de très grands
joueurs. J'ai décidé de lui faire
confiance.
Jamais remis en cause ma confiance. Je
suis quelqu'un d'assez fidèle. C'était
pas facile parce que tu sais quand tu es
en difficulté dans un club, tu as quand
même tous les agents qui t'appellent et
ils te font croire que tu es Maradona
quoi. Tu vois, ils vont te mettre 1 AC.
Et à chaque fois je disais non, vous
appelez Alain. Et alors lui faire
confiance c'était aussi pas savoir ce
qui se passait autour de moi parce que
lui me répétait, j'étais pas dans les
discussions. Quand tu vois Neymar là ce
qui s'est passé, si tu veux qu'on en
parle, bah Neymar, il est un joueur de
foot quoi. Et il sait pas ce que se
disent le Barça, le le PSG, la FIFA,
l'UFA pour le coup, les autres agents,
les autres clubs. lui, on lui rapporte
quelque chose. Il a beau avoir son père
qui est là, c'est quand même lui qui est
le dernier au courant de tout ça, il est
obligé de faire confiance à un système
qui qui est qui va pas le défendre, qui
va défendre leurs intérêts et pas et pas
les siens. Le plus grand perdant de
cette histoire, c'est forcément Neymar
et le joueur de foot.
Donc les joueurs de foot, tu vois pas de
mallette, les les centres de formation.
J'aime beaucoup les joueurs de foot,
c'est ce que je veux dire.
Ouais. Je suis un joueur de foot
quand on dit quand on dit voilà les
joueurs de quand on a reçu on a reçu
Lilian Turam
qu'on a beaucoup
ouais qui est qui est un cerveau. On on
l'a reçu parce que je l'ai rencontré à
la semaine des ambassadeurs
où j'ai un peu rué dans les brancards et
à l'entract il était venu me voir et il
m'a donné du courage. Il m'a dit ta
question là ils ont pas répondu à ta
question.
Et quelle était ta question ? Ouais,
c'était une question sur euh les la
schizophrénie française en terme de
diplomatie avec le Qatar et l'Arabie
Saoudite
et et euh
quand on l'a reçu derrière, on a pris
beaucoup de messages en disant "Mais
pourquoi vous avez reçu un joueur de
foot ? Ils sont stupides."
Hm.
C'est faux.
Ils sont pas
Tu connais Ribéry ?
Mais non, mais
parce que Ribéberry sur internet tout le
monde le prend pour un débile mental.
Alors alors
est-ce que qui est capable de prendre le
ballon
de tirer un penalty en finale de Coupe
du monde
avec 80000 personnes ?
Quel homme est capable de faire ça ?
tous ces types là qui disent que c'est
un appro quel homme est capable ça veut
dire que
ça peut être un penalty ou faire une
passe une passe juste. C'estàdire
rentrer sur un terrain avec un stress
énorme 80000 personnes, le destin de ton
pays entre les pieds. Tu es capable de
le faire techniquement, mentalement et
physiquement.
Tu es capable de de de d'avoir intégré
la défaite, l'échec, de t'en remettre.
Tu es capable de de recevoir le ballon
de quelqu'un.
de contrôler, de faire la passe au bon
endroit dans la bonne force, la bonne
distance, le bon effet pour que l'autre
il le récupère et l'autre il est c'est
adapté à ça. Prendre toutes ces
informations en même temps, au même
moment c'est déjà incroyable.
C'est pas ceux qui parlent le mieux qui
sont les plus intelligents. C'est ça.
Mais il y a aussi une question après
d'instruction,
d'éducation, de tout ces choses-là.
Voilà. Peut-être que Ribéry parle moins
bien français qu'un autre.
Je me sens bien plus proche de Ribéry.
euh que de plus grands intellectuels de
de la planète. Euh j'adore les
intellectuels aussi. Je suis
footballeur. Moi, je ce qui m' ce qui ce
qui me définit, c'est d'abord d'être
footballeur et je les défendrai toute ma
vie. Tu tu parles de de
Je déteste qu'on attaque un footballeur.
Tu tu parles quand quand euh tu parles
de de défendre son pays lors d'une Coupe
du monde.
H
euh est-ce que tu penses que les joueurs
qui jouent dans l'équipe de France sont
pas devenus tellement égoïstes,
tellement businessman, tellement euh
tout ça qu'ils en ont oublié que
derrière c'est la fierté d'un pays
ou est-ce que vraiment ils sont ils sont
vraiment fiers et ils jouent la main sur
le cœur. Je parler de mon expérience
personnelle, c'est plus simple. Euh
après, je pourrais essayer de de de
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé récemment
et aussi de 98. Mais euh on peut parler
aussi mon rapport à la France, tu vois.
C'est quoi pour moi être français ? J'en
sais rien, quoi. Franchement, euh tu
vois pas le voyage que j'ai fait, moi,
mes arrières grands-parents viennent de
l'Inde.
Tu parles Indie ?
Ouais.
Après c'est Hey
non, [raclement de gorge] je parle pas
indie. Moi, je parle mauricien. Mon père
parlait Tégou. On parle TGO, on vient de
l'Andra Pradesch. On a été
euh déplacé quand ils ont aboli
l'esclavage à l'île Maurice. Donc les
les esclaves travaillaient la canne, ils
abolissent l'esclavage. Ils vont
chercher de la main d'œuvre en en Inde
pas cher. Il les ramènent pour aller
travailler la canne. C'est comme ça que
mon arrière grand-père vient en Maurice.
Et mon père après avoir travaillé dans
les champs de canne à l'âge de 9 ans
jusqu'à à un certain temps, il avait un
peu monté. Il a décidé de venir en
France. pour un avenir meilleur. Il y
avait une une euh
il recrutait sur les chantiers navals,
il est devenu ouvriller, ma mère a été
cuisinière. Euh euh je suis devenu un un
joueur de l'équipe de France. Euh pour
moi, c'était euh le jour où je suis j'ai
été appelé en équipe de France. Pour
moi, c'était jouer avec les meilleurs et
contre les meilleurs. C'était
incroyable. Et puis euh quand la la
ligne nationale a retenti la première
fois où j'ai joué avec de France,
[__] c'était d'une puissance
incroyable quoi. J'étais tellement fier,
c'est tellement beau,
je pourrais, je sais pas. Et puis après,
je suis allé jouer au Milan AC
et puis un jour les mecs se moquaient
des Français et ça m'avait énerve. Je me
suis hyper énervé. J'ai et je me suis
rendu compte que ouais, je suis
français. J'aime la France. Euh mais
mais quels sont tu vois, mon père ne
parlait pas français, il était ilé,
il mangeait pas trop français, il avait
pas de pote français finalement et puis
il était français quoi. Il est venu ici
pour nous. Je suis français. Mes frères
et sœurs sont français sont français. Et
bah il y a d'autres manières d'être
français. Il y a plein de manières. Il
connaît pas la Marseillaise, il connaît
pas Marianne, l'Arc de Triance, il en a
rien à [__] Euh
l'église qui a brûlé Notre Dame de Paris
tape et pourtant il est français comme
je suis français. Euh
on a des histoires différentes. J'aurais
pu être ailleurs finalement et je suis
je suis là. Donc c'est
Éric Canton il dit il dit euh être
français en fait c'est ce serait
peut-être réveiller nos vieux démons,
retourner la table.
C'est ça veut dire quoi exactement ?
C'est-à-dire l'esprit révolutionnaire.
Bah de toute façon en fait ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui on a vu avec les
gilets jaunes. C'est pas la lettre de
Guimoket, c'est pas tout ça pour le avec
les gilets jaunes. On l'a vu récemment.
Je veux dire,
il faut rebousculer, rechanger
tout ça.
On essaie de nous imposer un modèle. Euh
là, je me souviens euh le rafel par
exemple qui avait euh qui avait qui
avait proposé de non qui avait imposé on
allait chanter la l'hymne nationale dans
toutes les compétitions euh nationales
de de sport. Euh il y a eu la lettre de
Guimoke pour Sarkozi, il y a Mais on
nous impose des choses. Moi euh
on m'a enfin mon père est venu
travailler pour la France. Il
s intégré par le boulot.
Est-ce qu'il s'est intégré ? Est-ce que
c'est important ? qui s'intègre. Est-ce
qu'on peut pas juste le laisser
tranquille ? Est-ce qu'on peut pas juste
laisser les gens vivre tranquilles ? Je
veux dire,
ton père était tranquille, c'estàd que
il imposait rien aux autres.
Il imposait rien aux autres. Il dérange
pas. Moi, il y a rien qui me dérange en
fait. Il y a rien du tout qui me
dérange. Donc je ne comprends pas qu'on
soit dérangé par
une femme en boubou, par des par le
rabbadan, par je ne comprends pas. Donc
je dois tout faire pour que les gens
acceptent tout ça. Je veux qu'on vive en
société ensemble. On doit pouvoir
quand on siffle la Marseillaise dans les
stades de foot, ça te fait quoi ?
Rien.
Est-ce que tu peux comprendre qu'il y a
des gens ça les blesse ?
Non.
Pourquoi ?
Par exemple
parce que c'est faux. Parce que c'est
faux. Parce que c'est faux. Notredame de
Paris. C'est faux. Les gens qui ont
pleuré. C'est peut-être vrai, hein. Il y
en a qui ont pleuré qui était touché
tout ça et tout. OK. Combien de choses
euh comme ça change ton quotidien ?
Combien de choses changent ton quotidien
? Les gens qui ont pleuré là, qui ont
choqué quand ça la Marseillaise a été
sifflé. Le lendemain matin, ils se
réveillent, ils sont traumatisés, ils
ont ils peuvent pas aller travailler.
C'est faux. C'est faux. C'est une
exploitation de quelque chose à chaque
fois. Les attentats bizarrement quand il
se passe à l'étranger partout, on s'en
moque parce que ça ça quand ça arrive
ici déjà on s'inquiète un peu plus.
Quand ça arrive à Paris alors là tu as
tous les Parisiens qui flippent et là ça
nous a touché. Là on a eu peur. On a eu
peur pourquoi ? On a eu peur pour nos
proches, notre famille. Tu sais quand il
y a les attentats, ce qui était très
marrant très pas très marrant mais
moi j'allais j'allais me coucher en plus
j'étais chez moi. Il y a les attentats.
Tu sais qui j'ai appelé en premier ? la
mère de mes enfants pour savoir où mes
gosses étaient et ma sœur qui habite à
Paris. J'ai pas appelé des potes, j'ai
pas appelé j'ai appelé la mère de mes
enfants et j'ai appelé ma sœur et après
j'ai appelé mes potes et après
évidemment quand j'ai vu tout ça ça m'a
évidemment bouleversé, touché. Je
Mais
j'essaie d'être le plus honnête
possible. Je je veux que tout ça change.
Je veux queon puisse vivre ensemble.
Pour moi, c'est le truc le plus
important, le vivre ensemble. Le lien
social.
Comment on fait pour préserver ce ce
lien social ? Faut le recréer. Il est
cassé
quand il y a un repli communautaire,
quand il y a du communautarisme parce
que les fondamentaux de l'économie
poussent à ça. Comment on fait pour
casser ce repli communautaire ? Par le
sport, par la culture, par la
Marseillaise, par le service militaire.
[rires]
Tu as fait l'armée ? Non.
Bah oui, j'ai fait l'armée. J'ai perdu
un nom de ma vie.
Pourquoi tu as perdu un nom de ta vie ?
Mais c'est horrible quoi.
Tu as appris à faire ton lit ?
On m'a forcé à tirer avec un famass. Je
Oui,
tuas pas forcé à tirer avec forcer.
Sinon j'allais t'
appris à défendre ton pays.
On m'a dit tire. J'ai dit non, on m'a
mis au cachot. Je suis sorti, je leur
dit vas-y, donnez-moi le flingue, faut
que je tire. Je veux plus retourner au
cachot. Euh j'ai appris la Marseillaise
là-bas. Sinon, je l'aurais pas, je sais
pas si Moi, je l'aurais peut-être
apprise ailleurs. Euh, ouais, j'ai perdu
un an de ma vie, quoi.
Je jouais au foot, pendant ce temps, les
mes potes, ils continuaient, j'allais
perdre ma place sur le terrain. Euh non,
un an de ma vie perdu quoi. On a on peut
tout allait bien à l'époque, 19 20 ans.
Le quartier, j'étais sorti du quartier.
Le vivre ensemble existait le lien
social. le vivre ensemble, le social, tu
vois, j'ai vraiment vu ce qui pouvait
abîmer ce trucl-là. Je viens d'un
quartier qui s'appelle Cocoville au
Havre.
Euh
euh je vivais au 7e étage à HLM. Mes
parents travaillaient, mon père était
ouvrier, ma mère était cuisinière. Et
vers 10 11 ans euh la crise pétrolière
est arrivée. 1 2e bam chômage. Mon père
n'allait plus travailler. Nous, on était
content, on savait pas, on comprenait
pas. Et d'un seul coup, tout se dégrade.
Tout se dégrade. Euh les communautés se
retournent vers leur communauté. Nous,
on avait un club dodo qui s'appelait le
club dodo. Le dodo, c'est l'emblème de
l'île Maurice. Le club de l'île Maurice,
c'est un seul coup toute la vie qu'il
avait parce que mon père était syndé et
donc il recevait beaucoup de monde à la
maison. C'était vraiment joyeux hein.
Des blancs, des des noirs et puis d'un
seul coup plus rien et tout le monde se
refme, tout le monde a peur de l'autre.
Puis d'un seul coup les 10 arrivent. Euh
je me souviens parce qu'il y avait le le
fantasme du sadic qui traîne dans les
dans les dans dans la dans la cave alors
que avant les caves c'était un endroit
où je joue à cache-cache parce que faut
savoir que toutes les caves communiquent
entre les immeubles. Donc on s'amusait
là-dedans et là plus rien tout ça comme
ça et on est parti. On est parti. Je me
souviens l'ascenseur n'était jamais en
panne et là il était tout le temps en
panne les donc il était en panne et les
gens ne viennent plus le réparé. On nous
abandonne, on nous laisse.
Tu vois d'autres pistes pour établir le
Ah non, je t'ai pas donné les pistes là.
Le football c'est génial. Le la
J'en ai des pistes évidemment. Euh
euh
le football c'est génial quand tu vois
même au niveau amateur et ça des fois ça
se termine en baston euh quand tu vas
dans les sonnes, ça se termine en
castagne.
Euh euh
j'ai j'ai connu un un des entraîneurs
euh des des Gaals du PSG et euh il
m'expliquait des trucs. Lui quelqu'un de
très droit et qui essayait de remettre
un portugais d'ailleurs
nationalisé naturalisé français. Euh euh
il y a même au niveau
amateur des aussi des tensions qui se
manifestent. Est-ce que tu penses
vraiment que le le foot est suffisamment
résilient pour passer au-dessus de ça ?
Alors, je je suis pas au fait de tout ce
qui se passe, mais tu sais, j'ai été
quand j'étais joueur de foot, j'avais
demandé à mon équipe mentier qui était
Puma de donner de l'argent et et des
équipements à mon club. Et puis j'avais
repris le petit club de quartier et puis
c'est vrai qu'après c'était devenu euh
il y a il y avait un peu les gangs dans
les équipes et tout et c'est vrai que
quand on allait jouer à l'extérieur
parfois ça se terminait en bagarre et et
donc on a j'avais arrêté et la violence
est arrivée. La violence est forcément
liée à à au chômage, dégradation du du
lien social et l'école évidemment
l'école qui fonctionne moins bien, la
famille fonctionne moins bien, le boulot
fonctionne pas, le politique lâche tout
ça, la défaillance un peu de tout le
monde et et le club de foot aussi à un
moment craque. Euh mais regarde l'équipe
de France qui joue, elle montre une
belle couleur, elle gagne, elle montre
aussi que on peut faire la passe à
l'autre, être avec l'autre et aller
ensemble vers quelque chose. C'est c'est
ça que propose le foot quand même. D'une
manière générale, tu peux pas tu peux
quand même pas jouer tout seul. Je veux
dire même Messi qui est le meilleur
joueur du monde, il a besoin de d'autres
gars pour faire la passe et puis aller
marquer un but. Faire la passe, c'est
quand même se lier, se relier, faire
société d'une certaine manière. Euh
quand tu quand tu quand je on met un
ballon quelque part, bizarrement tout de
suite on se met en rapport avec l'autre,
on entame une sorte de dialogue, de
discussion. Euh évidemment euh euh il
faut le mettre partout, il faut s'en
servir, c'est quand même gratos. Le le
sport, ça sert à quelque chose, ça sert
à ça. Euh mais comme plein d'autres
choses,
tu as pas tu as pas une vision un peu
idéalisée de
Bah, il faut rêver hein dans la vie. Il
faut être
alors que maintenant euh
et après Oui, non mais je reviens sur le
truc, il y a des problèmes dans la
société qui vont aussi maintenant dans
dans le foot et qui fonctionnent pas.
des on se retrouve avec des des équipes
de haut niveau avec des mentalités de
petits kit de banlieu des comportements
comme ça.
Tu es sûr de ça ?
Je sais pas, je reprends tes mots. C'est
toi qui qui en a parlé le Non non c'est
pas moi. C'était
Bachelot qui avait dit ça les cailles de
banlieu et les moi j'ai jamais dit ça
jamais de la vie. qui avait dit euh
après Taisna là, les petits cailles de
banlieu euh
et et c'est c'est très marrant tout ça
puisque euh ensuite on a on a dit que
les petits cahes de banlieu c'était euh
Benzema, Nasri, euh Benarfa euh qui
était même pas à cet endroit-là. C'est
génial quand même. Alors si si quand on
dit ça, on stigmatise pas l'islam, alors
là faut m'expliquer ce qui se passe
quoi. Et euh alors que en fait Knaisna
par exemple, c'était juste une grève euh
qui est pas allé au bout de son truc.
Des des petits mecs qu'on voulu faire
grève et après ils sont dit "Attends, on
va perdre nos avantages." Les agents ont
dû dire "Non, non, moi j'ai jamais dit
jamais pensé ça. Le foot représente les
quartiers, les banlieux. Les gens qui
sont dans les quartiers, dans les
banlieux sont en ce moment peut-être
majoritairement noirs et et arabes. Si
tu regardes bien avant dans les années
50, 60 70, le foot représentait toujours
les les vagues d'immigration avec les
Italiens, les Polonais, les les
Portugais. Euh voilà. Euh euh évidemment
euh euh c'est c'est bien le foot, mais
je pense qu'il faudrait aussi réussir à
qu'est-ce que tu peux répondre aux gens
qui disent "Voilà les Italiens, les
Portugais, les Polonais, ils sont très
très bien intégrés euh mais avec les
nouvelles vagues d'immigration euh ça se
fait plus."
Bah je me dis forcément que euh il y a
un il y a il y a peut-être un changement
vis-à-vis de l'islam. euh le l'islam et
nous on est catholique hein, je enfin on
est euh judéochrétiens. Euh euh donc euh
il y a
tu convertis, hein, je veux dire, tu
prends euh ça juste ça hein. Euh quand
tu pointes le droit les petits caïdes,
c'est bizarrement les petits rebux
musulmans. C'est pas euh c'est Bachelot,
c'est elle qui c'est ceux-là qui ont été
pointés. Euh les Sénégalais qui sont
musulmans parfois les et euh euh
cou les sénégalais.
Ah ben c'est mes amis, moi mes frères
sénégalais.
Sénégalais
mes frères sénégalais.
Mon pote sénégalais hier, il m'a dit
longue vie à toi.
Quand quand tu entends euh il y a pas
très longtemps, je crois que c'est ce
matin, Turam qui dit euh [soupir]
le racisme antiblanc, le racisme tout ça
là, c'est quoi cette histoire, cette
polémique encore ?
Le racisme antiolent.
Euh alors faut tu veux que je te raconte
un peu ce qui s'est passé ou bah les le
Lukaku est allé jouer avec l'Inter à ça
s'appelle l'international he le club
l'international faut savoir que c'est un
club qui a fait sission de Milan AC
parce que le Milan AC ne voulait pas
accueillir les étrangers et donc
l'international se crée pour accueillir
les les joueurs qui ne sont pas italiens
pas du Milan donc bam comme un peu la
Ladio avec la Roma La Ladiio c'est le
club ladaliste et la Roma c'est le club
qui est et c'est souvent comme ça un
gène ça doit être pareil. L'Espagnol
c'est pareil tu vois. L'Espagnol c'est
les espagnols et le le Barça, c'est les
catalans. Tu vois l'ag c'est pour ça que
ça s'appelle l'espagnol de Barcelon
parce queils accueillaient les les
espagnols, les castillons certain enfin
ceux qui parlent je pas je suis pas un
expert. Et
et au Lukaku qui joue à
l'internationale, ils vont jouer à
Caliari et il y a des crit pour lui et
donc il rentre donc pas de réaction de
personne, pas de réaction de de de la
ligue italienne. Il y a eu Moses Kin
l'année dernière quand même qui a été de
nouveau qui avait été aussi
victime de de de de cri de singe. Et
quand même le joueur Bonucci avait dit
il est à moitié responsable de ça comme
si on pouvait être responsable
de de du racisme. Enfin noir était
responsable de voilà c'est de ta faute
si tu es noir quoi. Tu qu' pas être
noir.
Etth et l'entraîneur Allégri avait dit
c'est pas grave non plus. Etci avait
joué capitaine et Moisés il avait été
sur le banc le match d'après. J'adore.
C'était fous ces gens. Et là, Lukaku,
les supporters de l'Inter ont fait une
lettre ouverte, un petit communiqué en
disant voilà c'était pas raciste. Faut
savoir que nous les italiens, c'est
comme ça qu'on veut déstabiliser les les
joueurs. C'est comme ça qu'on provoque
et voilà. Et sache que bah nous, on fait
comme ça aussi.
Donc Lilian Turam est intervenu en
disant plein de choses super en disant
que voilà
faudrait revoir les les vraiment ce
qu'il a dit que
l'Italie
le foot était pas raciste, mais il y
avait du racisme dans le foot qu'il
fallait lutter contre et que euh
je sais alors je sais plus exactement si
tu si tu l'as. Ouais,
vas-y, continue. Je vais le chercher.
Voilà. et que aussi c'était le problème
des blancs parce que c'est vous qui
c'est les blancs qui sont racistes. Donc
je dire c'est votre problème maintenant
débrouillez-vous pour plus être raciste
et que malheureusement on en souffre
nous du racisme et euh
et que alors je faudrait que tu
retrouves je suis en train de chercher
donc ça a été repris et euh il a été
accusé de racisme antiblanc de
généraliser sur les blancs et c'était
euh euh euh
du racisme inversé comme on dit.
souvent
il bon j'arrive pas le retrouver
j'arrive pasouver
et la licra là vient de
vient d'apprendre que la licra sos
racisme
abandonneuram
c'est ça hein il condamne les propos de
tiram mais c'est un sketch quoi.
Pourquoi c'est un sketch ? Mais comment
euh enfin déjà tout ce que dit Turam est
juste et je valide euh il faut euh
le racisme évidemment antiblanc n'existe
pas puisqu'il est pas systémique, il a
pas été hors la société française n'est
la société française ou blanche n'est
pas été organisée pour euh n'est pas
organisée pour discriminer l'homme
blanc, elle est elle a été organisée
pour discriminer l'homme noir. Et et il
faudrait aussi éduquer les gens,
apprendre l'esclavage,
ce qui s'est passé, comment ça s'est
passé, comment on a déporté des hommes,
comment on les a déplacé, comment on a
colonisé toute une partie de la de la
planète pour travailler dans les champs
de cannes, dans les champs de coton et
cetera. En Inde, c'est les Anglais qui
sont allés pour coloniser les les
Indiens. Et comment on a on a dit qu'on
a inventé ce racisme ? Donc comment on a
décidé que l'homme noir était pas l'égal
de l'homme blanc ? Était une source
carrément un animal et donc c'est pour
ça qu'on pouvait l'exploiter travailler
pardon les mettre dans des eaux
dans des eaux puis surtout on pouvait
les les martyrisrer jusqu'à les tuer.
Ils n'avaient pas de valeur. Ils étaient
là que pour travailler et c'est comme ça
que l'homme blanc s'est enrichi.
C'était déjà enrichi autrement en
exploitant l'homme blanc. L'homme blanc
exploitait déjà l'homme blanc. Alors
maintenant il est parti exploiter
l'homme noir et puis ils se sont
enrichis. C'est comme ça après qu'il
rapatriait les capitaux et qu'il
construisait enfin s'industrialisait et
puis continuait l'exploitation de
l'homme de par l'homme le capitalisme
ici ou ailleurs. Et c'est comme ça que
ça s'est construit et c'est comme ça que
l'homme blanc a dominé le monde. Ziggler
l'autre fois Jean Zigler que j'ai écouté
attentivement que j'adore et est
formidable. il disait quand même, il y a
12 % de la population qui est blanche et
qui domine le monde. J'ai récemment, je
m'amuse à regarder les instance de
direction, c'est un sketch quoi. Dans le
foot par exemple, c'est quand même des
footballeurs partout, noirs, arabes, il
faut savoir qu'il y a plus de 50 % 60 %
de joueurs de foot qui sont noir et
arabes. Il y a plus de 60 % de médaillé
au JO en France qui sont d'origine noire
et arabe. et ben le Cojo, le comité
d'organisation des Jeux Olympiques en
France pour Paris 2024, il y a un noir,
Bruno Marie, l'UNCATF, tu vois, j'ai vu
une photo, il y a pas de noir. La FIFA,
c'est pareil. Le gouvernement français,
c'est pareil. La mairie de Paris qui va
se les candidats qui vont se présenter,
zéro. Alors, on a imposé la parité. Donc
maintenant, il y a des femmes et des
hommes. Mais et donc euh par exemple
récemment pour lutter contre les
discriminations, contre le racisme, les
gens qui sont réunis pour lutter contre
ça sont tous blancs.
La Turam là, il y a le il y a la
communauté qui m'a fait remonter les les
On remercie Mozart euh dans une
interview mercredi au journal italien
Corè des
paralien.
Pourquoi tu bouges les mains ?
L'exfotballeur
l'ex footballeur champion du monde 1998
dénonce le racisme des sociétés
européennes caractérisé selon lui par
une sentiment de supériorité des blancs.
Tu peux redire ?
Ouais.
Pardon. Je
dénonce le racisme des sociétés
européennes caractérisées selon lui par
un sentiment de supériorité des blancs.
Bah oui. Oui. Il il dit il le sentent et
il le croit. Mais dans les faits, c'est
vrai. Je veux dire euh quand les
supporters du Caliarich font des cris de
singe, il montre bien que le blanc est
supérieur à l'homme noir qui est un
animal. Donc euh c'est la vérité. Et
donc euh euh insidieusement,
implicitement euh dans la conscience
collective, c'est quand même les blancs
qui dirigent et les noirs qui exécutent.
C'est comme ça. Euh dans toutes les inst
dirigeantes, les grandes instances
dirigeantes du monde capitaliste, c'est
l'homme blanc qui dirige le G7
récemment, on l' on a pu le voir, il y
avait donc euh que des blancs, un
japonais, une femme. Après, il y avait
tous les chefs d'état qui étaient là. Il
y avait trois femmes, je crois, sur 70
personnes, quelques chefs de euh donc
ils allaient ils allaient euh euh
parler des inégalités à travers le
monde. Donc forcément nord- sud, nord-
sud, noir blanc, homme-femme entre
blancs. Donc nous on n'est pas invité,
on va parler de nous.
Tu sais qu'on est dans un monde où il y
a l'Arabie Saoudite qui préside une
commission sur le loi des femmes.
Ouais. Voilà. Donc faudrait quand même
nous inviter et et nous faire participer
parce qu'on parle de nous.
Il y a quelqu'un qui te pose une
question. A-t-il reçu des cours
d'histoire notamment sur les
déportations et masculations des noirs
par les Arabes ?
Ça te parle ?
Non non non mais bon
sur le racisme
pourquoi il il essaie de me piéger sur
Ah bah t'inquiète, ils vont tous essayer
de teer.
Ouais ouais mais tu peux mais tu sais
comment dire euh
c'est pas te piéger. Non, non, mais il
peut me poser une question mais je vois
pas pourquoi euh
comment dire
par exemple à l'ICRA aujourd'hui SOS
racisme s'ils sont pas d'accord avec
Turap, pourquoi ils se tentent pas ? Tu
vois moi je je n'attaquerai jamais
quelqu'un qui est proche de ma cause.
Jamais. Je vais le soutenir ou je vais
la fermer. Si le mec il merde, je vais
la fermer. fait des conneries.
Je vais si si je sais que lui son enfin
Turam il défend cette cause, il se bat
pour quelque chose, la même cause que
SOS racisme et que euh et en plus alors
moi je valide tout ce qu'il a dit hein,
évidemment et je cautionne et je valide
et je je le soutiens. Et eux, ils ne
sont pas d'accord et ben ils doivent le
soutenir quand même parce que ils ont
une cause commune, c'est combattre les
discriminations et le racisme,
l'antisémitisme. Ils peuvent pas le
lâcher, ils doivent le soutenir. Et je
en plus je pense qu'ils font une erreur.
Il se trompe. Et de toute façon jusqu'à
présent, je veux dire pour Adama Traoré,
ils étaient pas là, on les a pas vu pour
la ligue pour Lukaku là plutôt que de
taper sur Turam, ils auraient pu
condamner les champs racistes de
Caliari, hein. Ils auraient pu faire ça.
Eux, ils ont préféré taper sur Turam qui
est en train de dénoncer quelque chose
de grave. Bah voilà, SOS racisme, la
licraiance
à ces gens-là. Je voudrais bien voir le
ca du de la licra. J'aimerais bien voir
qui dirige, qui sont ces gens qui
dirigent, euh comment c'est
subventionné, qui paye,
qui donne l'argent à à la licra.
J'aimerais bien savoir.
J'aimerais bien connaître.
Revenons sur le racisme antiblanc. Euh
euh
tu es le racist.
[rires]
Non mais
un blanc qui subit enfin le mec il est
est-ce qu'il a déjà été recalé en boîte
de nuit parce qu'il était blanc ? Est-ce
que est-ce que il a subi des contrôles
au faciè ? Est-ce qu'il
Moi, j'ai subi tout ça mais vraiment
vénère et mes potes encore plus que moi
parfois. Est-ce que moi j'ai appelé un
jour pour avoir un appartement et je
suis allé, on m'a dit "Mais vous allez
vivre à combien là-dedans ?
à Milan, je cours, contrôle de police.
Euh à Milan, j'arrive j'arrive avec la
poussette de ma fille. Euh j'étais à la
pharmacie et c'était il y avait un une
vitre comme ça à la pharmacie et c'était
un truc un peu tu sais opaque. Donc il
voyait pas ce que je poussais. Et
j'arrive et le mec me fait le mec me
fait "Non, non, par là, par là." Je dis
quoi ? Et et donc j'étais avec la donc
je je pars là-bas et je me rends compte
que c'est l'entrée des livreurs.
Euh
enfin c'est c'est
c'est voilà la différence la différence
c'est celle-là. Trouver un emploi.
J'ai une copine l'autre fois qui m'a dit
son pote il est il est il est rebeux, il
est musulman pour trouver un
appartement.
Ils allaient trouver un appartement
ensemble puis elle il voulait elle lui
dit "Bah vas-y, on y va ensemble." Il
dis non non vas-y toute seule. [rires]
Elle dit "Mais pourquoi ?" "Mais avec
moi tu vas pas la voir." Elle dit "Mais
non, tu es fou on y va." Ils y vont mais
ils l'ont pas eu. Puis elle y va seul,
ils l'ont.
quand quand il y a un repli
communautaire
et que et que dans certaines banlieux,
tu as des gamins blancs h
qui se font insulter genre de salle
blanc,
c'est pas ça ça arrive, ça arrive pas.
Bah ça doit pas arriver, je le ça je le
condamne et c'est euh tout ce qui est
méchant et qui peut blesser quelqu'un,
voilà, faut voilà, c'est c'est
évidemment euh euh voilà, faut pas le
faire, c'est pas bien. Euh voilà.
C'est tout. Faut faut faut pas que ça
arrive. Voilà. Mais si peut-être euh euh
je suis sûr que dans dans cet endroit-là
euh les conditions euh de vie sont pas
géniales et que évidemment euh à un
moment donné le l'histoire euh le que de
de ces historiques des noirs, des rebeux
qui ont été euh martyrisés, colonisés
revient sur le blanc et qui c'est c'est
leur envoyer le ce qui s'est passé il y
a des siècles. Donc tout ça, il faudrait
le raconter, l'expliquer à l'école. Je
viens d'aller en en Martinique.
Euh l'histoire de la Martinique, c'est
c'est un truc de fou.
Ah bah de la Guadeloupe aussi, hein.
Ouais, la Guadeloupe, mais ils ont ils
finissent autrement sur le Il y a pas de
béquet par exemple là-bas en Martinique,
il y a les béqués sans familles.
Sans famille qui ont tout.
Quand l'esclavage est aboli, on a
indemnisé les blancs et les noirs
n'avaient rien. Alors, vous êtes libre
mais vous avez rien.
Il il on tu sais qu'à un moment on
pouvait acheter sa liberté quand tu
étais noir. Tu pouvais te payer. Enfin
et là les 100 les 100 bqués alors ils
ont tout ils ont tous les terres, ils
ont tout euh
l'économie, ils sont sur des collines.
Ils se protègent et ils ont euh pas de
pouvoir politique parce qu'ils veulent
pas. Par contre, ils sont euh c'est eux
qui gèrent. Donc par exemple, tu vois
quand il y a quand il y a les il y a des
des grèves et tout, ils laissent faire
un petit peu puis au bout d'un moment,
ils appellent ils appellent le le le
type qui est en charge. Ouais, bon les
mecs là faut régler ça. Ils appellent le
préfet, ils font venir les cufs et hop
c'est fini. Voilà. Et tout ça géré parce
qu'en fait faut savoir que la Martinique
appartient à la France donc ne fait
aucun commerce.
avec dans les îles Caraïbes, elle fait
des commerces, elle fait partie de
l'Union européenne donc elle commerce
que avec l'Europe. Donc elle est gérée
par la France et la France veut pas la
Ch enfin c'est
sont pas libres encore là-bas.
Le on leur passe le bonjour.
Quand tu vois qu'il y a la polémique
avec Marline Marlène Chapa et les
slogans homophobes dans les stades et
que les supporters ont répondu "Bon en
gros, je résume trivialement,
nous prend pas pour des débiles mentaux
quand on voit la France traiter avec le
Qatar ou les homosexuels, c'est c'est
moins c'est les moins que rien.
C'est c'est un peu ambivalent ce que tu
nous dis. Qu'est-ce que tu en penses toi
? Bah de toute façon, je c'est c'est
vrai que la France est pas claire sur
plein plein plein plein de sujets
comme lesquels
comme voilà comme ce que tu disais aussi
la guerre au Yenilabie Saoudite.
Bah de toute façon moi je Macron je ils
viennent de voter le CTA et en même
temps ils me demandent de faire le trié
sélectif quoi. Donc vraiment juste tu as
envie de rire. tu vas dire à Bolano de
d'arrêter de brûler l'Amazonnie pour
s'enrichir et en même temps, tu fais du
libre échange avec ce pays-là et tu fais
rentrer d'autres d'autres denrées,
d'autres biens
qui sont
liés à la pollution, à la destruction de
la planète. Donc évidemment euh je
comprends euh voilà le ce que disent les
supporters. Euh néanmoins, bon il faut
que ça arrête, c'estes ces champ
homophobes dans les stades. Euh l'autre
fois j'étais euh il y avait une bonne
discussion entre un gars de des
supporters et et un type de rouge
direct, une association euh qui lutte
contre l'homophobie et le dialogue il
est là, ils vont trouver des solutions,
ça va s'arrêter. Euh les les supporters
en en utilisant ces ces ces banderoles
homophobes et en blessant des
homosexuels, il provoquait la ligue. Euh
est-ce qu'ils sont homosexuels ou pas,
il faut qu'ils arrêtent. Ils ont
d'autres moyens euh de de d'aller se
plaindre et d'aller combattre. Ils ont
ils sont dans la même situation
finalement parce qu'ils sont c'est une
sorte de discrimination aussi des
supporters qui ont plus le droit de se
déplacer dans on est dans un pays où le
préfet ou la ligue peut interdire aux
gens d'aller supporter leur club
arbitrairement comme ça. C'est l'état
policier qui décide. Vous ne pouvez pas
bouger, vous ne pouvez pas aller
supporter votre équipe.
Tu peux aussi comprendre c cet état où
il y a les ligan, ça casse tout, il se
fracasse. Quand il y a un match au parc,
on est obligé de de faire un périmètre
de sécurité avec des carts de CRS un peu
partout.
J'ai l'impression qu'on nous mend. J'ai
l'impression que c'est tout ça est faux
quoi. Tout tout est tout ça est une
construction.
Combien de matchs il y a t tous les
weekends à travers la France ? Combien
de matchs à travers le monde de football
? Combien de fois ça se passe mal ? Ça
se passe mal, c'est évidemment
dramatique, tragique, c'est trop, mais
en fait c'est très peu. Et à chaque
fois, on nous enlève une liberté. À
chaque fois, on nous met une loi de plus
pour nous taper dessus, pour nous pour
nous bloquer, pour nous enfermer. C'est
faux.
Tu sens une radicalisation de l'État ?
Bah, je le sens pas. Tu tu le sais, tu
te moques de moi là.
C'est un sketch quoi. Les gilets jaunes
qu'ils ont pris sur la tête. Tu as des
mecs je je le la police qui normalement
euh est là pour me rassurer. Elle est
là, je la paye en plus c'est avec mon
pognon. Je paye des gens pour pour
protéger l'État en fait. Pour protéger
les politiques et cetera. Ils son ils
sont on les protège à l'Élysée, à
Matignon et compagnie. Ils sont pas là,
ils sont là pour nous taper dessus. Non,
normalement, il devrait être là pour
nous rassurer. Moi, je devrais voir un
flic être content. C'est cool, mais je
devrais pas avoir peur de lui. J'ai fait
la manive du 1er mai. Moi, j'ai vu
comment ça a fonctionné. J'en ai j'en ai
fait d'autres avant, mais la manif du
1er mai avec les gilets jaunes et et euh
comment on était nassé et comment était
tout était organisé pour qu'à un moment
on pète un plomb. Il y avait aucune i
sur les côtés. tu ne pouvais pas
t'échapper. À un moment, on a fait
marche arrière parce qu'on sentait que
ça allait ça allait ça allait serrer et
euh donc on a fait marche arrière, on a
voulu sortir sur les côtés et là en fait
il y avait les flics qui nous
empêchaient. Il y avait des familles
avec des enfants, il y avait une femme
enceinte, il y avait des personnes âgées
qui ne pouvaient pas sortir, qui ont
commençait à s'énerver et c'est là ça
peut dégénérer. Ils ont intérêt que ça
dégénère ce genre de moment.
Pourquoi ?
Bah parce que après ils peuvent dire
voilà ça s'est mal passé donc on va
encore plus préprimer.
Moi je crois qu'en fait les gens si tu
les laisses pénard mais ça ça se
reconstruit tout ça parce qu' là
maintenant on a peur maintenant c'est
devenu un peu dangereux et ça ça se
reconstruit ce truc de liberté de cool
de vivre ensemble. Moi j'ai pas peur moi
quand je traverse la rue quand je me
balade dans la rue j'ai pas peur. J'ai
pas peur qu'il m'arrive quelque chose.
J'ai pas peur du tout.
Après il y a des endroits où c'est où
c'est dangereux hein.
Où ça
je sais que j'ai des copains ou des amis
ou des filles notamment qui qui sont à
la chapelle où c'est plus dangereux.
Voilà. pour les filles la nuit, plus
tard, dans certains endroits, c'est
dangereux. Donc il faut euh mais dans un
monde idéal, ça devrait marcher tout ça.
Ça devrait marcher.
Est-ce que tu peux comprendre aussi le
flic euh qui se reçoit des pavasses sur
la gueule euh des g d'acides euh des
choses comme ça ? Est-ce que tu peux
comprendre qu' qui se radicalise aussi
de côté ?
Bah ça doit pas arriver évidemment dans
les deux sens. Je fais l'avocat du B.
Oui oui, mais ça mais
euh
alors je sais plus com pas comment dire
ça mais
les on il y a du comment dit la
dépression chez les chez chez les flics
et cetera, du
suicide.
Il y a du suicide chez chez les flics.
Évidemment, ça doit pas arriver mais
c'est l'État qui crée ça. C'est l'État
qui les met en conflit avec, je veux
dire, ils sont du juste du mauvais côté
de la loi en fait.
En fait, on vit ensemble et on nous
oppose. Mais c'est Castaner et compagnie
qui crée ça, qui crée ses confesions,
cette
c'est eux qui le créent. C'est pas les
gilets jaunes.
C'est pas les gilets jaunes qui sont
responsables de la dépression ou des
suicides dans la chez chez les flics.
C'est l'État.
C'est c'est organisé pour que on soit en
en conflit. On devrait vivre ensemble.
Récemment, j'ai j'étais à un endroit euh
j'aime bien raconter des histoires.
On a le temps.
Ouais, j'étais j'étais il y avait un
petit barbecue sauvage chez des potes
dans le magasin. Puis il y a des flics,
il y avait Oxmo Puccino qui était là. Il
y a des filles qui ont reconnu Oxmo et
ouais, il y a Oxmo Puccino, ils se sont
arrêtés
et et ça commença à discuter, c'était
génial. Alors que euh ça buvait, il y en
avait qui fumaient des joints. Bah
ouais, ils sont juste du mauvais côté de
la loi quoi.
Est-ce que tu
suis un peu l'actualité en Inde ou pas
du tout ?
Au Cachemir, tu vas me parler.
Exactement.
Ouais. Il y a des conflits. Euh l'Inde,
ça craint là. On a enlevé des Bah, c'est
l'extrémisme
hindou hindouisti, je sais pas trop
comment on dit. C'est un un hindou qui
est qui est au pouvoir et qui euh qui
voilà, il y a des musulmans qui ont été
euh destitués de la
à bat. Voilà. Qu'est-ce que la
[grognement] Ouais, c'est un vrai grand
problème. C'est très étrange parce qu'en
même temps, il y a pas si longtemps, moi
je suis allé en Inde plusieurs fois et
je me disais c'est quand même une
démocratie incroyable quoi qui
fonctionne alors qu'il y a des des
casses des des centaines de millions de
personnes qui crèvent la dalle. Et
comment ils s'entretuent pas ? il
s'entretuent un peu quand même. Il y a
des conflits, hein.
Voilà, c'est bah nous aussi, il faut
qu'on bouge sur tous ces ces conflits,
ces problèmes. L'extrémisme
il arrive au pouvoir un peu partout, il
arrive aussi là-bas et il va tuer des
gens. Les le euh les problèmes sociaux
euh se transformment en xénophobie, en
racisme, en etmène des gens comme ça au
pouvoir. Salini en Italie, Borolano,
Trump. Euh
je parle sous je parle sous ton
contrôle. Ils ont pas dépénalisé
récemment l'homosexualité en Inde ? Ah,
je sais pas là je suis là tu m'as tu la
communauté ça
communauté mais ça ça me rend triste moi
tu sais euh je je me sens très indien
euh très très indien ma culture était
très forte
indienne à la maison euh je suis allé en
Inde un jour et j'étais avec mon pote et
puis on se promenait et puis je j'étais
dans la rue il est parti et puis
j'attendais un coin de rue et il y a une
personne qui est venue et qui m'a dit
"Je cherche ma route où c'est" et je me
suis dit
C'est mon pays quoi. Je suis indien. Je
suis indien et je suis français aussi.
Sur l'homosexualité avec le foot, tu
penses que vraiment ça va s'arranger ?
Est-ce qu'il faut vraiment éduquer les
gens ? C'est-à-dire arrêter les matchs
quand il y a des choses qui qui
dégénèrent ?
Alors, l'homosexualité, le racisme, le
sexisme,
il faut lutter contre une discrimination
évidemment ensemble.
Euh
c'est euh
pas c'est impossible de les dissocier.
Euh et moi je pense que les
la seule peur de la ligue de football,
c'est que le match s'arrête mais
définitivement
parce que le show s'arrêtera à ce
moment-là. Et les droits de télévision,
c'est plus important que tout. le foot
qu'on vend. Tu sais pourquoi euh
on met des cartons jaunes aux joueurs
qui enlèvent leur maillot ? Tu sais pas
? Tu vois, tu marques un but, tu es
content, tu enlèves ton maillot. Tu sais
pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait, le moment
où tu marques le but et ben on doit voir
la pub.
Si tu enlèves ton maillot, on ne voit
plus la pub. Conforama, je sais pas
quoi.
Et ben, c'est le seul truc que le joueur
de foot
doit attaquer que le show s'arrête. Si
jamais les joueurs de foot, je sais pas
si tu remarqué à chaque fois qu'il y a
des choses qui arrivent comme ça, c'est
la prochaine fois, la prochaine fois on
arrêtera le match. Alors ça dure parce
que à chaque fois la prochaine fois
enfin dans le match la prochaine fois la
prochaine fois ça n'arrive pas souvent
puisque les gens ils ont peur, ils
veulent continuer le match. Même les
entraîneurs, mêmeoiré l'autre fois avec
Prince Guayano, Comboiré qui est noir,
il lui a dit "Vas-y, on rejoue, on
rejoue, on rejoue."
Bah non, on arrête le match les gars un
moment parce qu'on a dit qu'on arrêtait
le match mais non, on narrête pas le
match. Et donc la prochaine fois, c'est
forcément dans une autre ville, dans un
autre stade avec des nouveaux joueurs et
des nouveaux racistes. Donc on redit la
prochaine fois
ou des nouveaux homophobes
et les nouveaux homophobes la prochaine
fois et la prochaine fois ça n'arrive
pas. Et euh donc moi je suis sûr que les
joueurs de nouveau mais pour tous les
joueurs sont les hommes forts. C'est eux
qui ont le pouvoir. Neymar, Messi,
Ronaldo. Si un jour ils décident
ensemble d'arrêter et ben ils vont faire
peur à la FIFA. Tu vois récemment Messi,
il a lourdement critiqué la Fédération
sud-américaine puis qui en disant "Vous
êtes des corrompus et tout ça." Bah
c'est vrai, ils sont des corrompus. Moi,
j'en suis sûr. C'est approuvé, hein.
J'ai l'impression que c'est vrai. Et
puis il s'est excusé derrière.
C'est dommage. Il s'excusé. Neymar, il
s'est excusé aussi pour son pour son
quand il a il a enfin non, je sais pas
si s'est excusé mais en tout cas, il a
pris quelques matchs, tu sais, quand il
a dit que les arbitres avaient triché
sur la main de Kim Pembeé
pour le Var. C'est le Var. Le Var, les
joueurs par exemple, ils peuvent décider
de refuser le VAR.
Tu vois, ils ont même pas été consultés.
Les joueurs ont un pouvoir énorme. C'est
de toute façon tu sais c'est un peu dire
c'est comme dans le dans le monde du
travail dire ça force du travail et puis
le les moyens de production là ils
organisent et eux ils jouent mais en
fait s'ils arrêtent de jouer il y a plus
rien au-dessus hein. Dire la FIFA
n'existe pas hein. Le foot pourra
continuer toute sa vie
sans la FIFA. Par contre la FIFA
n'existe pas si Neymar il arrête de
jouer au foot. Et c'est là que les
footballeurs, ils comprennent pas ça.
Ils peuvent changer les choses. Alors
évidemment
envie, ils ont peut-être ils
ont pas envie parce qu'il y a des
contrats. On les a payé tellement cher
que ils ont perdu leur liberté.
C'est normal de payer aussi cher des
gens.
Alors c'est c'est un drôle de d'endroit
parce que souvent le capitalisme il
fonctionne sur
gagner travailler beaucoup et produire
très vite et et tu es pas payé pour ce
que tu travailles. Alors là, est-ce que
tu es payé pour ce que tu travailles ?
quand tu es touché là c'est l'inverse
peut-être tu es peut-être trop payé mais
il y en a quand même beaucoup qui sont
très mal payés beaucoup de précarité
beaucoup de chômage dans le football tu
vois Neymar euh c'est peu de joueurs qui
touchent beaucoup d'argent comme ça et
en échange c'est aussi un endroit très
étrange où quand tu as un échange de
joueur il y a un échange d'argent il y a
pas beaucoup de métiers si tu pars des
sauts à total
à part une clause de confidentialité un
truc comme ça il y a pas d'argent argent
qui circule, tu peux casser ton CDD, tu
peux être licencié.
C'est des CDD qu'on casse euh et on a
intérêt à le casser. On a jamais intérêt
à ce qu'il a eu au bout parce que sinon
il y a pas de transfert. Donc on rachète
un joueur pour son talent, son âge et la
durée de son contrat et on casse le CDD,
on le fait aller ailleurs et on valorise
ce truc, c'est ses côtés, je sais pas
trop comment il faut. Et là, tout le
monde s'en met plein les poches. Et
Neymar, bon bah je sais pas les agents,
les rétrocommissions, les directeurs
sportifs, les présidents, je sais pas
trop comment comment ils s'arrangent
entre eux. Euh société offshore, je sais
pas trop. Et le joueur, il en prend sa
part, le père du joueur et cetera et
cetera. Neymar là, il s'est fait piéger
parce que en pendant énormément
d'argent, en payant sa clause
libératoire, il s'est retrouvé coincé
puisqu'il a plus de clause. Ce que j'ai
aimé, c'est quand même qu'il a voulu
racheter son contrat. Ça, j'ai adoré. Il
a quand même voulu donner 20 millions
d'euros. Alors, j'aimerais qu'un joueur
un jour arrive et dise "Moi, je rachète
Neymar, je me rachète quoi." Avec
[grognement] 20 millions d'euros, il
avait sa jambe gauche, hein, pas plus,
hein. Euh, mais bon,
il a été contraint à jouer. Alors là,
par exemple, tu vois euh Neymar, il a
deux solutions.
Euh jouer ou pas jouer, il a le droit,
hein. Alors, jouer, c'est bien joué ou
mal joué. il a plutôt intérêt à bien
jouer. Il a aussi la possibilité
d'arriver tous les vendredis avec un
certificat médical et dire "Oh, j'ai
mal, j'ai mal là, je peux pas jouer." Et
là, qu'est-ce que le Qatar peut faire ?
C'est une guerre, une guerre. Soit
Neymar, c'est 3 ans de contrat, qui
tient le coup et part à un moment parce
que le Qatar est obligé de le laisser,
soit le Qatar le laisse à pas jouer
pendant 3 ans,
mais il le fera pas Neymar. Je pense
pas. Je pense qu'il va jouer pour
inverser les rapports de force.
Bon courage le On va parler
Rabio l'a fait hein mais ça a duré que 6
mois.
On va parler du football féminin.
Pourquoi elles sont pas autant
médiatisées ? Pourquoi on les met pas
plus en avant ? Bah
c'est de nouveau
en plus elles jouent mieux. Non
oui mais c'est de nouveau la société
son elles sont moins souvent par terre
elles font moins souvent de s'imagrer.
Puis c'est super. Et puis Rapino, c'est
une femme fantastique. C'était Mais
j'étais tellement content qu'elle gagne
la Coupe du monde et qu'elle marque en
finale. Voilà, je pour ce qu'elle a
voilà une femme euh qui se bat par
exemple, tu vois Kperik, tu vois le le
qui qui se bat pour contre le racisme
aux États-Unis, contre Trump et tout et
ben elle est une femme blanche qui
défend euh la cause noire. Bah c'est ça
la vie, c'est que tout le le racisme, on
en parlait tout à l'heure, la cause la
cause des femmes, c'est la cause de tout
le monde. La cause des noirs, c'est la
cause de tout le monde. La cause c'est
on a des des enfin, on vit en société,
on vit ensemble. C'est notre histoire.
la l'histoire. Bizarrement, quand on
parle de l'histoire, c'est l'histoire
des blancs et c'est l'histoire de tout
le monde. Mais quand on parle de
l'histoire des noirs, c'est que
l'histoire des noirs. Bah non, c'est
l'histoire de tout le monde. Il y a un
super interview d'un joueur américain de
de Basket qui parle de ça. Comment les
blancs doivent soit la fermer, soit
participer au combat mais jamais faire
la licra là, la licra
lâcher le combat de Turam. Ils ont lâché
le combat de Turam. C'est des traîtres.
Et pour le football féminin, évidemment
l'égalité
euh il y a pas il y a pas de
il y a l'égalité ou pas l'égalité.
Voilà, il y a pas de niveau d'égalité,
c'est l'égalité ou pas d'égalité. Et
tout a été construit depuis très
longtemps parce qu'il faut savoir que
dans début du siècle, le football
féminin était quelque chose qui
fonctionnait très bien, qui marchait
très bien, qui remplissait les stades et
on a tout fait pour que les femmes
retournent au fourneau en disant
qu'elles avaient pas de légitimité, que
c'était moins bonne et cetera et cetera.
Et donc après euh
on en arrive à ce que les femmes ne
jouent plus au football et quand elles
jouent on dit que il faut qu'elle génère
autant d'argent que les l'homme pour
pouvoir toucher le même salaire. Euh bah
non, je dire tant qu'on leur donnera pas
le même salaire, il y aura pas d'égalité
et tant qu'on les rendra pas visibles.
Là, il faut savoir que le handball
féminin, champion du monde ou d'Europe,
n'a pas de de diffuseur
en France. Il n'a pas de diffuseur
récemment. Tu verrais des des des matchs
mixtes.
Pourquoi pas ? Ouais, pourquoi pas ? Il
il y a la mixité jusqu'à un moment.
Aujourd'hui, il y a peut-être des
différences qui font que ça s'arrête.
Mais pourquoi pas ?
De toute façon, tu sais, c'est Idriss
Abarken que tu as que tu as reçu qui dit
les révolutions, les changements,
c'est toujours ridicule,
dangereux, évident.
Aujourd'hui, on rigole quand on dit
l'égalité salariale. Bon, l'égalité
salariale pour les femmes et les hommes
à travers
la société partout,
c'est pas gagné.
Et dans le foot, là on rigole. Et ben un
jour ce sera dangereux parce que ça va
commencer à arriver puis un jour ce sera
évident. Le droit de vote, ça s'est
passé comme ça. Le droit de vote pour
les femmes, les gens rigolaient puis
après ah merde [__] fait chier. Puis
en plus tu as l'air d'un con parce que
c'est en train d'arriver. Donc tous les
intellos qui disaient euh euh faut pas
le faire et tout, ils ont l'air de con.
Et puis d'un seul coup, ça arrive et
tout le monde dit "Ah bah oui, c'était
normal, c'est toujours comme ça." Et ben
euh moi, j'ai fait plein plein de de
plateaux pour défendre cette égalité
salariale qui est pour moi quelque chose
de très important. Euh là, les anglais
viennent de l'imposer dans les équipes
nationales. Alors, dans le privé, Holas,
il fait ce qu'il veut, hein. Je crois
qu' il fait bien avec son équipe
féminine, mais il [grognement] a le
droit, c'est son problème, même s'il
faut le combattre, il faut faire en
sorte de que ça avance. Mais euh dans la
Fédération Française de Foot par
exemple, c'est la la Fédération
Française de Foot dans ses statuts euh
doit lutter contre toutes les les
discriminations de genre euh dans le
monde du foot. il doit organiser le
football de masse. À aucun moment il a
l'obligation de gagner la Coupe du
monde. Il est hors de ses statuts quand
il ne donne pas le même salaire à ses
aux femmes et aux hommes. Alors, ils
vont dire que la FIFA donne moins
d'argent en fonction des compétitions.
Faut savoir que les Américaines
qui sont triple championn, qui
remplissent des stades, qui font gagner
de l'argent à la Fédération américaine,
sont moins payés que les hommes qui
n'ont même pas joué la dernière Coupe du
monde. et elles viennent perdre, elles
viennent de perdre de nouveau dans leur
conflit avec leur fédération.
Les Françaises
par exemple,
si on faisait puisque l'argent c'est la
Fédération qui la reçoit, qui reçoit cet
argent, il pourrait tout mélanger et
redistribuer. Euh je suis sûr que si on
disait à Griezmann Pogba qu'ils sont des
gens très bien euh et tous les autres,
on leur disait "Mais en fait il faut
partager, il dirait bah oui évidemment.
Bizarrement, c'est ceux qui dirigent et
de nouveau des hommes
qui refusent ça. Tu sais, il y a une
petite histoire du château, je sais pas
si tu avais suivi ce petite histoire du
château. Les filles étaient au château
de Clarefontaine euh et elle préparait
la coupe du monde et les hommes devaient
préparer un match éliminatoire pour
l'Euro, je crois, ou un truc comme ça ou
un match amical. Et les hommes sont
arrivés, elles ont dégagé, elles sont
parties dans un autre endroit.
C'est normal, c'est le château des
hommes. Non, c'est pas la Fédération
française de foot des hommes, c'est la
Fédération française de football. Et là
encore euh même Corindia qui a dit
"C'est normal historiquement". Mais non,
c'est pas normal. C'est pas normal. Et
je suis sûr et certain que si on avait
demandé à Griezman, Pogba, Mbappé, à ces
petits gamins jeunes ouverts d'esprit,
euh sympa, est-ce que vous voulez
laisser le château ? Ils auraient dit
"Mais vas-y, nous on va aller là-bas et
on va gagner. Vous inquiétez pas,
j'en suis sûr.
C'est compliqué hein.
C'est verrouillé. C'est verrouillé.
J'étais un truc sur le Je sais plus
c'était quoi ta question au départ déjà
? C'était sur les femmes.
Football football féminin.
Ben ouais, l'égalité. Sur un plateau, on
m'a dit "Ouais, il y a une un jour dans
le débat, on m'a dit il y a une limite à
l'égalité homme-femme." Bah oui, il y a
qu'une limite, c'est l'égalité quoi mec.
Il y a pas d'autres limite.
Qui c'est qui a dit ça ? Je dirais pas.
On va revenir euh sur l'égalité. Euh
j'ai écouté cet après-midi une vidéo de
toi et tu parlais de d'un buffet qui
était organisé par ton entraîneur et euh
il voulait un buffet à l'al
et tu disais bah on est dans un pays
laïque, on fait pas de buffet à l'alle.
Non, j' alors en fait moi je m'en tape
he qu' a un buffet à l'al ou pas. Euh
pour éviter les problèmes, il aurait dû
faire un buffet àal, un buffet pas à
l'AL. Je pense que ça aurait été ça.
Après, c'était Raymondom, hein. C'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup, qui a
beaucoup compté pour moi, qui a toujours
tout fait pour
tout ce truc de vivre ensemble, de lien
social. C'est un mec génial. Et donc
mais c'était ce truc là où je savais que
comme le buffet était à l'al, ça allait
être repris et on allait stigmatiser,
donner le bâton pour taper encore sur
l'islam. Et je me disais ben plutôt que
de taper sur l'islam en mettant qu'un
buffet à l'al et que on dise après "ça y
est l'islam nous envahit. Ça y est euh
on va se convertir à l'islam." Je
m'étais dit "Bon bah vaut mieux mettre
un buffet àal, un buffet euh je sais pas
cacher, un buffet tout ce que tu veux.
Celui qui bouffe de la viande, bah il y
a la viande et voilà. Et aussi un buffet
qui est pas à l'al comme ça tu prends
pas de risque. Mais en fait mo moi tu ce
que tu veux.
Tu connais des végétariens dans le monde
du foot professionnel ?
Euh non. C'est je me dis que les
Indiens, ils peuvent pas y arriver dans
le foot. Alors, c'est une blague he
comme la moitié de la population est
végétarienne, il bouffe du curry à
longueur de journée comme moi. Euh,
c'est pour peut-être pour ça qu'ils ont
pas une grande équipe de de football,
mais c'est pas pour ça du tout puisque
en fait ils sont en 1950 à la Coupe du
monde, ils arrivent piednus, on leur
refuse de jouer et on refuse les Indiens
et ils rentrent et et le le football
décline à ce moment-là. Est-ce que tu
vois d'autres pistes pour sauver la la
cohésion sociale en France ? Parce que
là, tu connais la chaîne YouTube depuis
un certain nombre de d'émissions et je
dirais d'années.
On parle d'économie. Tu as une formation
en économie toi ? Non.
Euh moi j'ai fait ouais j'ai fait de
l'économie. Je suis pas allé loin. J'ai
j'ai passé mon bac A1 à l'époque. C'est
un bac assez dur par correspondance pour
les pour les gens là qui disent que les
les footballeurs sont des abrutis euh
tout seul. Donc parce que j'étais au
centre de formation. Mes frères et sœurs
sont tous diplômés. Euh et puis après je
suis allé à la fac et après j'ai
commencé à jouer avec les pros. J'ai
allé à la fac parce que j'ai je voulais
avoir cette carte étudiante. À l'époque
je rentrais pas en boîte de nuit avec la
carte étudiante. Dans les soirées
étudiantes, je savais que j'allais
rentrer. On allait pas pouvoir me
recaler et euh et donc c'était hyper
important. Et puis après j'ai commencé à
jouer, j'ai arrêté. J'aimais bien aussi
aller jouer aux échecs avec dans les
foyers africains qui qui étaient autour
de de la fac. C'était vachement
important pour moi.
Tu veux te lancer en politique ?
Évidemment
j'ai je j'ai toujours fait de la
politique. La vie c'est politique, tout
est politique.
Le sport c'est politique.
C celui qui dit "Je fais pas de
politique" déjà il est de droite. Et
celui qui dit "Je m'intéresse pas à la
politique", il est forcément de droite.
C'est marrant ça parce que les gens de
gauche le disent. Je suis de gauche.
Bon, c'est une conviction profonde. Je
suis de gauche. Je suis un homme de
gauche de très à gauche.
Jean Zigler, il dit
euh il a le livre que j'ai lu qui est
formidable. Il est formidable cet homme.
Il est incroyable. C'est surtout très
rigolo
puis c'est formidable quoi. Il m'a il
ces gens-là Michel Ser lui Badou des moi
je tu sais j'arnaque tout le monde je je
suis trois mecs à chaque fois et mais
c'est passionnant des gens qui se
battent depuis toujours pour quelque
chose et qui te Moi, il me guide ces
gens. Zigler, tu lui as posé à un moment
la question "Mais pourquoi tu fais ça ?
T'endors, comment tu fais pour dormir ?"
Il a dit "C'est pas important comment je
fais pour dormir ? Par contre, je vais
continuer parce que j'ai
une responsabilité de le faire. Moi,
homme blanc privilégié, je dois le
faire. Je dois aller libérer quelqu'un
d'autre. Je me suis un peu libéré. Moi,
je me sens un peu libéré. Un peu libre
même si je suis salarié d'une entreprise
et que j'ai des patrons et cetera. Mais
bon, je peux aller libérer quelqu'un
d'autre. Je dois le faire parce que tu
sais, parfois, j'ai envie d'abandonner
hein, parce que tu as envie, tu es là,
tu as assis, tu dis "Putain, mais j'ai
envie d'être peinard." Puis le
lendemain, j'y retourne. J'y arrive pas.
J'y arrive pas. Je dois aller libérer
les autres. Je c'est c'est je me trompe
peut-être hein. Et Jean Digler, il dit
qu'il faut détruire le capitalisme. Le
capitalisme expliquait à ma fille en
espérant qu'on enverra la fin. J'adore.
C'est incroyable. Il en verra peut-être
pas la fin mais il se sera battu toute
sa vie. C'est très important.
[grognement]
Badou dit un truc. son livre Attention
euh à l'homme blanc euh merde
euh enfant du rivage ou un truc comme
ça. Je sais plus ce livre qui est super
comment il parle de la colonisation et
cetera. C'est c'est génial. Est-ce que
tu trouves les gens de gauche des fois
vraiment intolérants par rapport à des
idées qui ne sont pas les leurs et euh
est-ce que par exemple toi en tant
qu'homme de gauche
h
tu dirais discuter
échanger avec quelqu'un qui n'est pas
tes opinions politiques et même à
l'inverse de tes opinions politiques ?
Oui, évidemment. Ouais. Mais je crois
que dans dans ce genre de discussion ou
de débat, il faut pas essayer de
convertir l'autre. C'est pas possible.
C'est des mondes qui s'opposent.
Je vais pas essayer d'avoir raison.
dire je je pense que le capitalisme et
tue la planète, tue les hommes, détruit
et eux par exemple ruissellement et
cetera, ils pensent autre chose. Est-ce
que dans ces deux conceptions
euh est-ce qu'on veut la même chose être
heureux et cetera ? Est-ce que c'est la
est-ce que
avancer ensemble ? Est-ce que c'est la
même chose et que il il croit en ça et
moi je crois en ça. Je pense qu'il se
trompe. Je pense que nous on a raison.
Et l'histoire montre aujourd'hui que
Jean Zigler le dit encore une fois, il y
a un enfant qui meurt de faim toutes les
5 secondes parce que le capitalisme tue.
Tu vois c'est pas euh
c'est pas je suis contre la mort la fin
dans le monde, tu vois. C'est pas euh tu
vois un homme de droite qui dit "Je suis
contre la fin dans le monde".
Il y a des gens de droite qui sont
contre
voilà, ils le disent évidemment, ils
sont contre la fin dans le monde. Non,
un enfant meurt
il et les gens ils racontent comment cet
enfant meurt et pourquoi pourquoi le
capitalisme tue ces ces ces gens euh
aujourd'hui ? Il y a il y a quoi
aujourd'hui comme sujet ? L'écologie et
les migrants. Et les migrants, c'est
quoi ? C'est des c'est de la fuite de la
misère dû à l'écologie, dû à à comment
on exploite la planète et comment on
maltraite la planète et comment on
déséquilibre.
Oui, mais l'économie c'est quoi ? C'est
aussi le réchauffement de la planète et
cetera. C'est euh abîmer la la la la
couche de zone et les catastrophes
naturelles et cetera et cetera, les
sécheresses, enfin tout est lié à ça. Et
donc les gens, ils partent, ils fuient
parce que nous on est en train de les
tuer et on va continuer.
C'est voilà. Donc il faut régler ce
problème. Il faut Et
comment tu fais pour régler ce
problème-là ?
Bah moi je sais hein, mais je il faut
prendre le pouvoir.
Tu prends le pouvoir comment ?
Bah ça je sais pas. Alors là
bah je sais pas quoi. Je veux dire faut
euh
c'est pas une révolution des consciences
qu'il faut.
Bah il faut peut-être une révolution
quoi. Peut-être une révolution.
Un philosophe un philosophe indien qui
s'appelle Krishna Murti. [soupir]
On est un milliard 500 millions mec.
Comment tu veux que je connaisse ? Lui
c'est
Je suis sûr qu'après cette émission
tuiras le pot
J'irai le voir. Moi j'écoute beaucoup un
un petit euh un gourou spirituel qui
s'appelle Sadgourou qui est génial qui
fait des petits trucs. Il est tout le
temps mort de rire et tout qui est
génial. Je l'écoute souvent.
J'ai pas fini. Tu m'avais posé une
question avant mais tuis posé une
question ou sur les les gens de droite
et les gens de
Est-ce que tu discuter avec un raciste
par exemple ?
Est-ce que c'est intéressant quoi ?
Est-ce que je peux lui faire changer
d'avis ?
Je vois bien là en ce moment, moi j'ai
j'ai je je tweet un peu
des choses j'ai mis récemment bon salut
les hommes blancs du G7
par provocation et parce que c'est vrai.
J'ai évidemment rien contre les blancs.
J'ai contre ces sep personnes et comment
le monde il est organisé et et les les
gens de rassau, tu es raciste,
antiblanc, c'est l'extrême droite qui
m'a attaqué. C'est les gens d'extrême
droite qui sont venus me mettre des
commentaires. J'en ai juste rien à
faire. J'ai identifié mon ennemi à ce
moment-là. Je sais que ces gens-là
veulent me faire la peau parce que ils
sont racistes eux ces gens-là et ils
supportent pas que je leur dise "Bah
oui, le monde il est organisé comme ça."
Je leur dis. Donc évidemment il faut
changer tout ça mais c'est compliqué,
c'est verrouillé. Ran Bronco l'explique
bien dans son livre. Ran, comment
l'entreo la cooptation s'organise pour
pour protéger les intérêts des uns et
des autres. Begodo, on parle aussi dans
ces dans dans comment le
Je te coupe une question de Tatiana. Euh
quelles sont les trois actions choses
qu'il ferait si euh il arrive au
pouvoir, si tu avais le pouvoir,
les trois actions,
chose qu'il ferait dès qu'il aurait le
pouvoir.
Si
imagine toi, je te donne une baguette
tout de suite là. Je te mets président
de la République française.
Tu te vois là avec les charpes et tout,
les clairons, les trompettes.
Je fais un truc déjà un gouvernement
plein de mixité et de diversité, un vrai
truc mélangé, des jeunes, des vieux, un
truc avec des discussions,
on partage, on fait ensemble, on fait
ensemble. Je me mets au service des
gens, pas à mon service. La fonction
euh, tu vois bien tous ces gens qui sont
au pouvoir, ils sont ils sortent des
mêmes écoles et c'est un métier. Ils
sont
ils font une carrière,
ils n'ont pas travaillé de leur vie, ils
sont même parfois pas élus jusqu'à une
élection parce qu'en fait ils sont ils
sont placés par là puis un moment ils
sont élus et donc ils protègent leurs
intérêts et ils protègent le leur
carrière et ils servent le grand
capital. Donc moi, évidemment, c'est
tout vers le public, tout vers le euh le
les plus démunis, tout vers le les plus
fragiles, c'est euh par exemple euh
l'école, l'hôpital, euh l'éducation,
l'éducation très importante, euh le
sport, la jeunesse, euh c'est tout ça le
progrès, évidemment, qu'est-ce qu'on
fait du projet, comment la recherche,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la recherche ?
Comment on s'organise ? Et évidemment,
sortir de la société de consommation,
sortir de la je ne consomme pas moi.
J'essaie je veux je fais mon
je fais mon mieux, j'achète des tennis.
J'aime bien mes tennis
tes chaussettes.
Ouais, j'aime bien. J'achète des tennis,
j'essaie j'essaie de de consommer mais
moi je suis pas responsable de ce qui se
passe he franchement je suis tout seul
hein. J'ai pas tué la planète. On est on
essaie de nous culpabiliser sur
individuellement alors que eux ils
signent le CTA et euh il le libre
échange euh ils s'arrangent entre le
privé et le public pour faire des
allers-retour et s'organiser pour se
placer et puis après subventionner euh
les uns et les autres. Il créer des
poches fiscales et cetera. Bon
Thomas Porcher pourrait expliquer tout
ça bien bien mieux que les niches
fiscales.
D'ailleurs, on d'habitude on a pas
d'autres boutilles en plastique mais
bon.
Et juste un truc pour finir euh
et bah
le les
le cas 40 les milliardaires, bah je les
dépouille quoi. Je les dépouille quoi.
C'est faut aller leur prendre leurs
milliards quoi. Ça sert à quoi ?
C'est comment pour aller prendre leurs
milliards ? Mais ils se sont quand tu es
milliardaire, tu as forcément volé,
triché, exproprié. Tu peux pas t'être
enrichi sans avoir triché, sans avoir
été dégueulasse. C'est impossible. Ils
ont volé les gens et ben il faut aller
le reprendre. Merci patron de Ruffin. Il
explique comment ça se passe et puis bon
on pourrait bah faut aller un moment
voilà, on les taxe à 100 %
et il se il se barrent dans d'autres
paradis fiscaux. Bah oui, c'est c'est
intraçable ces histoires avec les
sociétés offshore et tout ça. Je pense
qu'on peut comment dire la croissance,
ça sert à rien la croissance parce que
en fait tu vois bien que moi j'habite
aux ABÈ
j'ai pas besoin de de d'un de m'acheter
des vêtements quand je rentre dans un je
rentre plus dans les magasins. J'ai pas
besoin de deux paires de lunettes. J'ai
pas besoin de tout ça. Et nous on nous
dit de consommer. Il faut qu'on consomme
et c'est un truc qui c'est une fuite en
avant. En fait, on a pas besoin de tout
ça. Il faut sortir de la société de
consommation. Faut qu'on se voit plus,
faut qu'on se parle plus, faut qu'on se
croise plus.
Tu sais ce qui se passe si euh la
consommation ralentit ? Tu quelles sont
les répercussions sur le système
financier si la la consommation ralentit
? Est-ce que tu as essayé de creuser ce
sujet-là ?
Je suis pas un expert de ça. J'imagine
que leurs marchés vont s'effondrer, la
confiance va va perdre et ils vont
flipper et ça et leur truc peut
s'écrouler. Mais euh je suis sûr que eux
s'ils s'écroulent en fait euh je veux
dire par exemple euh
l'endettement là, tu vois l'endettement
là, moi je vois bien là, j'ai j'ai lu
récemment sur euh euh ADP, sur les
autoroutes, sur notre hôpital qu'on
vend, on a vendu euh je crois la
privatisation, on a vendu quand même
l'hôtel Dieu, 80 millions de d'euros à à
quelqu'un qui va en faire un hôtel de
luxe, des trucs, notre hôpital quoi.
Je crois que les autoroutes c'était 2
milliards. Ça ça rapporte 2 milliards
les autor enfin pas les autoroutes.
Oui, les autoroutes je crois ça rapporte
2 milliards je crois 3 milliards. Et on
les a vendu 3 milliards. Alors en fait
on a vendu quelque chose qui rapporte de
l'argent à l'État et pour Mais c'est
n'importe quoi. ADP c'est quelque chose
qui rapporte de l'argent à l'État.
Pourquoi on le donne au privé ?
La française des jeux.
La fran Ah voilà, c'était la française
des jeux je dont je je parlais. La
française des jeux. Ça rapporte 3
millions 3 milliards à l'État. Pourquoi
on le on le donne ? Pourquoi on le garde
pas ? C'est un patrimoine. Euh j'aime
bien
peut-être tellement slip qu'on a besoin
de récupérer du cognon et on vend les
les bijoux de famille. Non, on a
tellement peut-être le le gouvernement
mais on nous ment sur l'endettement par
exemple. Tu vois
pourquoi ?
Bah on nous ment euh bah on n'est pas
endetté puisque en fait on rembourse sur
des années. On est on a une dette d'une
année, on dit ouais on est endetté cette
année. Mais en fait on rembourse sur
plein d'années et en fait en face on a
un patrimoine qui est quand même plus
supérieur à notre endettement. Donc on
n'est pas endetté. Moi, quand j'ai une
maison, je la rembourse bien sur 25 ans
et donc euh la maison, elle vaut plus
cher que mon remboursement, enfin mon
emprunt. Donc je je suis pas le jour où
j'ai un problème, je vends ma maison et
je rembourse mon emprunt et j'ai gagné
un peu d'argent en plus. Donc je suis
pas endetté. C'est pas vrai.
Je sais pas si tu as une inversion des
taux.
Ah ça je sais pas.
On va faire une émission comme ça dans
pas très longtemps. Mais tu vois tout
toute cette construction sur les marchés
et cetera euh je veux dire
on pourrait faire autrement.
Comment ?
Mais j'en sais rien. Mais on pourrait
faire autrement.
Tu sens que ça sent le roussi ?
Ah ouais,
les gens sont en colère. [grognement]
Ça sent le
gilet jaunes c'était pas loin.
C'était pas loin. Rufin il a dit un truc
super sur la Moi je j'aime bien Ruffin
et il y va sur 2008 avec les les sub et
tout ça là. ce qui s'est passé, ça a
failli s'effondrer mais on avait pas
prévu le coup d'après. On avait pas, il
y avait rien. Donc ils ont renflué les
banques. Hop. Et là, il disait si jamais
ça se reproduit, il faut qu'on soit prêt
à voir faire des propositions. Et lui,
il réfléchissait à ses propositions.
Donc réfléchissons, moi je je connais
pas mais réfléchissons à ces
propositions.
Déjà appliquer le Glass Eagle Act
détail et les banques d'affaires.
Question de de Cédric. Balancez pas trop
de questions en même temps parce que je
perds ma ligne les gars.
Question de Cédric. Combien il gagne
actuellement ? Que fait-il de son argent
?
Moi
ouais
euh je je suis payé par Yao et par
l'équipe et puis
comment tu gagnes ?
Je sais pas je c'est important.
Je peux te dire ce que j'ai gagné par ex
quand j'étais joueur de foot par
exemple. Ça me pose aucun problème.
À Lyon il y a eu un moment j'étais un
des joueurs les plus payés de France.
Euh je touchais à peu près 130000 €
150000 €
par mois et j'avais pris des grosses
primes de signature. En sachant
qu'aujourd'hui des joueurs moyens
pourraient toucher ça quoi. Et puis au
Milan, je touchais un Mlon de net
d'impôts, un truc comme ça. Voilà,
j'étais en salarié d'une entreprise et
j'avais négocié un contrat. Euh voilà,
nous les footballeurs, c'est c'est tu
sais le sport dans le dans le PIB de la
France, c'est très petit. Ça doit être
0,80 je crois de dans le PIB. Le foot,
c'est quelque chose qui est à
l'intérieur des 0,80 € et les
footballeurs très payés, c'est quelque
chose d'à l'intérieur de à l'intérieur
de 0,80 €. Donc c'est vraiment pas
grand-chose quoi.
Actuellement, combien l'équipe et Yao te
paye ?
Beaucoup moins.
Je vais toucher allez 100000 balles par
an.
Voilà. Euh
moi ce que ce que je veux c'est que
les milliardaires, je m'en fous en fait,
tu sais. Mais sauf que ça peut pas
marcher. Mais en fait les milliardires
qui soient riches, moi ça m'en je m'en
moque moi. Par contre qu'on qu'on
s'organise pour que ceux d'en dessous
aille mieux, oui, j'ai aucun problème à
avec les lois qui pourraient favoriser
ça.
Une autre question. Quonnaît-il euh et
que pensent-t-il de la théorie de
l'effondrement ? Est-ce que tu es
collapsologue ?
Est-ce que ça déjà disparaître,
s'arrêter ? Est-ce que par exemple
Ouais, ouais. que que ça mon ça s'arrête
quoi. C'est fini euh ça.
Bah ouais, j'ai j'ai lu des trucs comme
ça. Bah c'est c'est pas mal ce truc
parce que si jamais ça s'arrête
vraiment, faut vraiment que je kiffe
tout de suite quoi. Parce que ça sera ça
serait mais c'est un peu comme pour la
mort quoi. Finalement, c'est parce queon
a on a on a peur de mourir qu'on qu'on
sort dans la rue quoi.
D'ailleurs, les quand on les riches, ils
veulent l'immortalité. Ils cherchent les
mortalités et en fait si un jour ils
sont
voilà, ils essayent enfin Google et
compagnie ils ont vachement investi
là-dessus mais s'ils deviennent
immortels, ils pourront plus sortir
puisque en fait c'est en traversant la
rue qu'ils pourront mourir ou en prenant
une balle.
Euh je suis pas un expert de tout ça.
Évidemment, on a un problème avec
le fait de d'être sur une planète qui a
priori a pas des ressources infini et
qu'on peut pas en fait non, elle de elle
est elle est elle est capable de se
renouveler et nous sauf qu'on est allé
plus on l' on l'a comment dire pillé et
on est en train de faire en sorte
qu'elle pourra pas se renouveler et que
à un moment donné on aura plus de
ressources pour nous et on on va en
crever quoi ou on va s'entretuer où il y
a des gens qui vont se barricader
quelque part. pour se protéger qu'on
voilà les parfois je me dis mais les
riches sont en train de s'organiser
quoi. Ils sont en train de s'organiser
parce qu'ils se préparent à ce que nous
on est plus et que on aille les chercher
et que eux ils seront organisés avec des
armes et et tout ça parce qu'évidemment
eux ils ont un coup d'avance sur nous
sur ces trucs là. Quand je pense à à au
bio aujourd'hui, euh c'est devenu de la
l'agroalimentaire bio. De nouveau, on
produit de façon industrielle avec des
des conditions de travail horribles. Et
c'est de nouveau les mêmes groupes qui
sont malins qui voient que c'est le bio
et qui alors on mange du bio, il y a pas
de pesticides mais en même temps on
maltraite qui
augmentent leur marge de 40 %. de
nouveau, ils vont et et c'est pareil
pour aussi je me demande s'ils ont pas
déjà les ressources renouvelables, enfin
je sais pas comment on appelle ça,
les énergies renouvel
énergies renouvelables et cetera, ils
les ont, ils les ont en stock, ils les
gardent, ils ont déjà mis la main dessus
et pour l'instant ils vont épuiser tout
ce qui est pétrole et cetera et une fois
qu'ils auront bien épuisé tout ça, ils
vont sortir les trucs. En fait, nous on
est on sait que en fait si on commence à
à bien s'organiser, il y a il y a moyen
d'être d'avoir des systèmes vertueux. Et
ben eux, ils vont le faire pour eux,
pour leur business, pour s'enrichir
encore.
Question d'Exos 7.
Oh, j'espère qu'il va pas envoyer un
missile.
Je crois qu' d'ailleurs il est plus
produit d'ailleurs celui-là. Euh, est-ce
que tu te considères comme riche ?
Bah, je suis plus riche que les autres.
Oui, oui, oui, je me considère comme
riche. Oui, je j'ai j'ai pas de problème
pour euh
Question de d'Oscar. Tu crois en Dieu ?
Euh alors je finis sur euh riche euh
mais moi je paye mes impôts. Je euh
alors donc c'est la première façon de
redonner la société. Euh je vais
m'engager en politique, c'est sûr et
certain. Je suis très à gauche. Euh je
milite, j'ai été parrain du Paris Foot
Gay. Je milite toutes les
discriminations. J'ai une association
qui s'appelle Tatane. On redonne
gratuitement notre temps libre et
cetera. Il y en a plein d'autres qui
font plein plein d'autres choses
formidables qui font bien plus que moi.
On essaie de faire ce qu'on peut. Euh je
veux faire plus, je vais essayer de
faire plus. Je vais m'engager en
politique. Il y a la il y a la il y a
les municipales qui arrivent. C'est sûr
et certain que je je vais bouger. Ce
sera forcément à gauche. Euh ça sera
forcément vers l'écologie. Euh les
migrants, anticapitaliste, de toute
façon euh euh le nouveau communisme
comme dit Badou et l'écologie est
forcément communiste. Tu peux pas être
Ouais. Mais l'écologie est aussi droite,
hein. Il y a des écologies droites.
C'est pas possible. Tu peux pas tu peux
pas produire euh être pour la
croissance, être pour la société de
consommation et en même temps dire aux
gens de faire le rentrée sélectif, c'est
pas possible. Ça peut pas c'est c'est il
faut tout l'inverse, c'est pas possible.
Tu peux pas kiffer aller t'acheter plein
de vêtements et dire je suis pour
l'écologie.
Tu peux pas aller bouffer chez McDo et
enfin tu c'est pas non tu peux pas tu
peux pas être pour euh le CTA et en même
temps pour l'écologie. C'est pas
possible.
Je peux pas être pour la croissance
exponentielle et pour l'écologie.
Bah ça c'est pas possible. tu tu es
c'est forcément anticapitaliste, c'est
forcément contre la croissance, c'est
forcément euh communiste. Je Il y a
plein d'endroits où ça a marché hein le
communisme. Euh et on nous fait croire
que ça a pas marché, ça a tué des gens
parce que c'est ce qu'ils disent les
gens quand
l'anarchisme. Ouais, bah évidemment, moi
je pourrais être euh là, je pourrais
être art euh mais je bon je sais pas
comment ça fonctionne l'anarchie mais
euh tu vois le les l'état euh fort et
tout ça euh si on s'organisait, on était
capable de s'organiser, être heureux
tous ensemble. Euh ouais, c'est pas trop
tard.
Pour toi, tu esard toi.
Il faut pas le dire.
[raclement de gorge] Tu es pas Tu es pas
euh
C'est pas trop tard ça ? Il y a il y a
tu sais récemment
euh
je défends Rufin, j'attaque les ultra
riches, j'attaque l'entre soi, la
cooptation de du pouvoir, comment euh il
s'amuse entre eux, il se Moscovici en ce
là, il vient d'être il va être nommé à
la Cour des comptes quoi. J'ai vu son
c'est un palmarès quoi, le gars. Euh
on va on va le recevoir là. C'est vrai.
B, tu pourras lui dire, c'est un sketch,
quoi.
Euh et euh
et on m'a on m'a on m'a on m'a dit
récemment euh "Oui, mais arrête
d'attaquer les ultra riches, qu'est-ce
que tu en veux ? On en a besoin dans la
société. Déjà, c'est faux, on en a pas
besoin parce que s'ils arrêtent, nous,
on continue. Euh,
j'aimais bien Paron Charlot qui te
montre, tu sais, la pyramide là où eux
ils sont tout en haut, ils sont très
peu. Ben, en fait, si elle tombe, cette
eux si si nous on arrête, ça s'écroule.
Si eux ils tombent, ça s'écroule pas. Et
euh
euh et on m'a on m'a dit "Oui, mais
voilà euh pour les hôpitaux, on a besoin
d'eux pour ça, on a besoin d'eux ce qui
est faux puisque'en fait ils payent pas
leurs impôts, ils tuent l'hôpital et ils
créent des hôpitaux privés pour eux où
ils vont euh ils favorisent le privé, le
l'école privée et cetera et les
assurances tout ça. Et donc nous ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens ne pourront pas
s'assurer, ne pourra pas être protégés
et cetera. Elle me et la personne me dit
"Mais et ça on pourra pas le changer ?"
Et moi je lui ai répondu "Tu sais je
suis on peut discuter de tout ce que tu
as dit là. Par contre le on ne pourra
pas le changer. Je suis pas d'accord. On
peut changer les choses. D'ailleurs, moi
quand j'avais 11 ans,
euh on c'était le HAC Cooville Dep euh
Cocrioville Lillebonne en levé de rideau
du HAC je sais plus quoi. J'avais 11 ans
au stade des Chasau. On perdait 2-0 à la
mi-temps du match et si on faisait match
nul, on allait en finale régionale de
Coupe de France, tu vois. Finale
régional puis après tu allais j'ai pris
la balle deux fois et on a fait 22. J'ai
changé le cours d'un match. J'ai changé
le cours d'un match en finale de Coupe
de France récemment.
Je viens avec des copains de sauver un
petit terrain de foot dans un squir
public. Il faut que je te raconte ça
après.
On peut changer les choses. C'est pas
forcément formidable ce que j'ai fait.
C'est pas euh comment dire
merde comment dire spectaculaire
mais on peut le faire et je dois tenter
de le faire.
Question de Vincent.
Tu m'avais posé une autre question tout
à l'heure sur Attends, je te raconte le
petit le petit terrain de du Squareburg
quand même parce que ça c'est très
important. C'est ce qui me fait y croire
de nouveau. J'habite aux ABÈ il y a un
square qui s'appelle le square burk.
Euh moi j'y allais avant mes filles
allaient, il y avait un petit toboggan.
Ils ont enlevé le toboggan. Ils ont mis
un petit terrain de foot tout petit, 100
m² dans 1600 m² avec
C'est très beau. Il y a la maison de
Dalida, il y a le le
le bateau la voir et tout aussi
au-dessus des beaux appartements qui ont
vu sur le squir. Le moi j'ai commencé à
jouer avec les gamins, avec le petit
frère de de mes filles qui s'appelle
Cassidi. On y allait et les gamins du
quartier qui n'y allaient pas parce
qu'en fait il y avait pas de de foot.
Ils jouaient dans la rue ou ils jouaient
ailleurs où ils allaient ils se sont mis
à jouer, c'était génial. Et nous un jour
on a appris que ils allaient enlever le
petit terrain. Les Rivins avaient fait
une pétition pour l'enlever pour
diverses raisons. Le bruit, euh le
cheat, les dealers, euh le le la nuit,
euh trop de trop de gamins, euh
discrimination des filles, euh qu'est-ce
qu'il y avait encore ? Ça a masqué du
racisme, ça masquait les le parc, c'est
leur jardin, ça masquait le prix du
mètre carré qui va baisser, ça masquait
tout ça. On s'est battu, on a sauvé le
petit terrain. Il va rester le petit
terrain. Ça veut dire qu'on peut changer
les choses.
Question de Vincent.
Je posé un autre truc tout à l'heure, je
m'en souviens plus.
Ça va revenir. Question de Vincent. Le
communisme a marché dans quel pays au
juste et qu'est-ce que tu appelles
marché ?
Bah Sankara,
Siraléon.
Chavez récemment. Euh il y a d'autres il
y a d'autres endroits communisme il y a
il y a plus longtemps je pense qu'on
connaît pas. Euh le Vénus là, il va pas
très bien.
Oui bah il est Ouais sans caras ça a
marché. On l' fait et aussi on l'a tué.
Ouais on les a assassiné. Les Américains
débarquent souvent parce qu'en fait ils
voi que ça marche et donc si ça marche
ça tue le business. Donc il faut pas que
ça marche. Et le et tu verras sans caras
c'est incroyable. Le mec était
féministe, écologiste et euh dans le
communisme. He c'est ça hein. Marx
c'était pareil hein. Marx c'est euh il
dit il dit un truc qui est génial. Euh
le le capitalisme épuisse épuise autant
les hommes que la terre.
Il y a plein d'autres exemples.
Autre question.
[__] tu avais posé une question qui
était super. Il fallait que je te je te
je t'y réponde à cette question
sur la politique.
Ouais, sur la politique.
Ça va revenir. Est-ce que tu as un un
avis ? Euh question de KNA. Son avis sur
les citoyens favorables à une
immigration contrôlée.
[rires]
Favorable à quoi une immigration
contrôlée ? Faut contrôler
l'immigration. C'est ça.
Est-ce que son avis sur les citoyens
favorables à une immigration contrôlée
sur donc sur les gens qui veulent
empêcher euh
sur les gens qui veulent une immigration
contrôlée
contre les contrôles. On compte les
quotas. Bah c'est un peu ça non ?
Fermeture des frontières avec on remet
des des douanes et cetera et on on
empêche les gens de rentrer dans le
pays. Et donc après on va sélectionner
l'immigration, c'est tout ça les trucs
contrôlés. Bon moi qu'est-ce que j'en
pense ? Mais je pense qu'il faut ouvrir
tout ça quoi. Je dire faut ouvrir, faut
accueillir, faut je veux dire
d'un coup il faut faire comment ?
Bah évidemment d'un coup mais d'un coup
ça marche pas parce qu'il faut il faut
il faut des lois, il faut préparer et
cetera. Mais
est-ce que est-ce que culturellement
parlant
si si on ouvre comme ça
quand on est Attends juste
est-ce que les gens vont s'intégrer ?
Mais ils ont pas besoin de s'intégrer.
Pourquoi ils s'intégreraient ?
C'est la France.
Mais pourquoi on doit s'intégrer ?
Pourquoi on doit changer les gens ?
Pourquoi les gens doivent apprendre la
langue française ? J'ai joué dans des
équipes de foot. Zlatan, pourquoi il
apprend pas la langue française lui ?
Pourquoi il parle suédois et pourquoi il
parle anglais ? Pourquoi ? Pourquoi dans
mes dans mes équipes de foot les
Brésiliens parlaient Brésiliens, il y en
avait qui apprenaient, qui apprenaient
pas ? Pourquoi quand on est blanc, on
est un expatrié quand on va à l'étranger
? Pourquoi nous quand on va à
l'étranger, nous sommes des expatriés et
quand les gens viennent ici, ils sont
des immigrés, des migrants. Pourquoi
tout ça ? Est-ce que tu vois
pourquoi mon père ne parlait pas
français ? Il était français, il se
sentait français. Il a fait ça pour
nous, pour ses enfants, pour un avenir
meilleur. Il est venu pour travailler,
hein, pour aider la France, hein. Tu
crois que les gens qui viennent ici qui
fuient la misère,
ils le font par plaisir,
ils fuient la misère, ils prennent des
risques, ils quittent leur famille, leur
culture,
je sais pas, c'est enfin
est-ce que tu vois un appel à la prière
dans la creuse à 6h du matin au lieu de
Évidemment
d'entendre le bruit des cloches ?
Évidemment, je rien à faire. Après ça,
ça me réveille, ça va être chiant quoi.
J'ai envie de dormir. J'aime bien. 6h ça
va. Moi 7h je me lève.
Le Tu sais le truc du bruit là de du
squar burk tout ça, les habitudes,
la peur en fait, la peur qu'on prenne ta
place. C'est une grande peur ça chez
l'être humain. La peur qu'on te pique ta
place. Euh donc là je vois bien le petit
terrain Burc. Une fois cette peur
passée, là ça commence à marcher
puisqu'il les reste, les gens commencent
à s'habituer. Les on change nos
habitudes, on se mélange, on se on
partage, on accepte l'autre, on le prend
comme il est, on ouvre son esprit,
on accueille.
L'Union européenne pour toi.
L'Union européenne,
est-ce que c'est bien ? C'est pas bien ?
Bah pas celle qu'on a construite
malheureusement. Elle on n pas réussi à
s'harmoniser socialement, fiscalement.
Euh on n pas réussi dire l'euro est pas
aussi fort à enfin on a dévalué les
monnaies. Enfin l'euro est pas aussi
fort à la main d'œuvre polonaise
roumaine, elle est moins for elle est
elle est sous-payée par rapport tout ça
ça va pas. Euh on est en concurrence à
l'intérieur de notre propre euh
construction européenne. Donc c'est
dommage. On a au lieu de le faire
ensemble, les affait déjà l'un contre
l'autre à l'intérieur. Euh d'ailleurs,
les les onglais veulent en sortir.
On me dit on me dit euh dans le chat que
c'est la question sur Dieu que tu
recherches.
Ah voilà, c'est ça. Oui. Bah ça
m'intéresse beaucoup quoi.
Merci Chogun.
Ouais ouais. Bah mon petit euh mon S
gourou là, je regardais l'autre fois un
truc et euh il disait
euh euh les choses si elles te tombent
dessus euh bah en fait c'est ce que tu
en fais. Tu vois si tu restes dans ton
canapé en gros
euh si tu fous rien Dieu tu peux lui
demander ce que tu veux, il va rien se
passer quoi. Par contre si tu fais des
choses, peut-être que Dieu il va
t'aider. les forces, les il y a des
choses qu'on contrôle pas, qu'on ne
maîtrise pas. Je sais pas je sais pas
comment le dire. Je crois en quelque
chose qui me dépasse et et qui veut
qu'on fasse des choses ensemble. Je
crois beaucoup à l'entraide. Le le j'ai
je je peux vraiment parler de mon
expérience. Le le football,
je dois recevoir la passe de quelqu'un.
J'ai appris à jouer au football. On m'a
appris à jouer au football. J'ai
confiance à mon entraîneur.
Je j'ai confiance mon partenaire qui me
fait la passe. Moi, je dois avoir
confiance à mon partenaire à qui je fais
la passe. Puis il y a un truc là qui
m'appartient plus quoi. Je connais ce
que j'ai fait, j'ai appris, je connais
la situation,
j'aime ce trucl mais après on le fait
ensemble. Le foot montre ça. C'est très
bizarre parce que moi dans le foot,
alors que je te raconte ça, euh je
j'étais incapable de faire avec les
autres. Je demandais pas d'aide. Je
demandais je disais pas que j'étais
vulnérable. Euh j'étais pas je disais
pas que j'avais mal. Je disais pas que
j'étais fatigué. Je voulais jouer parce
que j'avais peur qu'on me pique ma
place. J'avais peur de perdre ma place.
J'avais peur qu'on me voit pas et
cetera. Et puis quand je sors du foot,
quand je reviens dans la société, je
veux fonctionner comme ça et ça marche
pas. C'est très bizarre ce que tu dis
quand tu reviens dans la société.
Ah ouais, bah c'était un moment très
étrange le le football c'est j'ai réussi
à rester connecté politiquement et
cetera. J'ai continué à à tu vois j'ai
j'ai soutenu Golen Royal la parfait.
Ouais. [rires]
Hollande par exemple la loi la loi les
60 % de d'impôts. J'étais évidemment
pour je suis même pour une tranche à 100
%. Euh et euh et en même temps bah
ouais, j'étais dans un monde de ouf
quoi. Euh et j'ai réussi à à rester
connecté. Donc évidemment quand je
reviens, j'arrête le foot, je me
retrouve là, je me suis retrouvé à la
NPE quand même et puis moi j'ai voulu
fonctionner tout seul de nouveau euh
comme ça ça marche pas quoi. À un moment
j'étais obligé de demander de l'aide aux
autres, de faire avec les autres et là
c'est cool quoi. Et là c'est génial le
vivre ensemble, le lien social toujours,
c'est hyper important. Et tu sais
l'empathie, on a besoin de se voir et de
se croiser
et bienveillance.
Il y a il y avait un truc là sur euh
sur Dieu.
Non
non non sur ce truc de
de confiance et de et de et de de faire
ensemble. Mais bon ça me reviendra.
Question de 7. Euh euh veut-il abolir
les États-nations ?
Bah c'est marrant parce que depuis tout
à l'heure je te dis que je suis pas je
suis français, je sais pas ce que c'est
et tout ça et en même temps je me sens
français. Bah j'aime bien enfin je sais
pas j'ai pas de réponse à ça quoi. Tu
citoyen du monde là tu vois les trucs
comme ça là il y a il y a un mec qui dit
si tu es pour ouvrir les frontières sans
les contrôler c'est la même chose qu'une
maison sans porte d'entrée.
Bah ouais c'est Kaddafi qui avait dit
ça. La la la maison appartient à celui
qui habite. Il avait empêché les verrous
à l'intérieur. Euh c'était la il rêvait
du
l'arrabist la grande Afrique et cetera.
C'est marrant cette histoire. Le le la
propriété c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable quand même. Il faut abolir
il faut abolir la propriété.
Évidemment. Ouais, c'est c'est c'est
terrible être propriétaire. D'ailleurs,
c'est SarkoZi qui nous a forcé à être
propriétaire. Mais propriétaire qui les
riches ils s'endettent pas. Soyez
propriétaire les amis, endettz-vous.
Allez-y. En plus, vous aurez des primes.
Mais oui, ça m'appartient. Je le
protège. Bah non, ça t'appartient pas.
C'est c'est c'est quand tu quand tu me
le donnes, ça m'appartient. Ça
appartient à tout le monde. D'ailleurs,
je devrais je devrais pouvoir te prêter
mon t-shirt là. Tiens, tu le veux ?
C'est pas la même taille.
Mais oui, la propriété c'est c'est un
changement dans la dans l'histoire de de
l'humanité. Je pense quand on devient
propriétaire, on devient il y a aussi un
truc sur être sédentaire aussi,
j'imagine.
Faut-il libéraliser les drogues aussi
dans le sport, le foot ?
Bah, je suis contre le
Alors, c'est très compliqué parce qu'il
y a un problème sanitaire. Alors, c'est
pas par rapport au foot. euh sur le
dopage évidemment. Euh
donc c'est une grosse démagogie, je veux
dire, on demande aux gens de courage
s'en mettre en en 4 secondes et on leur
demande de le faire à l'eau clair quoi.
Euh et en même temps le dopage est en
retard sur la est en avance sur la lutte
antidopage.
Toi tu as tapé quand tu étais jeune.
Bah non, je je alors on était nous le
foot, tu sais, on a un rapport très fort
à la douleur et donc on on marche aux
anesthésions, aux antidouleurs, aux au
aux
infiltrations. Après, on va faire des
massages. et cetera et cetera. Donc on
est à la limite, faut savoir comment
fonctionne le dopage. Il y a des listes
et il y a aussi des beaucoup de choses
qu'on sécrète nous-même. Donc c'est des
taux. On va arbitrairement choisir un
taux et on va rentrer au pas dedans.
Mais on peut l'augmenter, le descendre.
Euh moi, si on m'avait demandé de
prendre telle drogue ou tel caché pour
jouer la finale de la Coupe du monde,
mais je l'aurais prise direct. Tu vois,
il y a il y a une légende sur Erric
Cantona qui dit dans le vestiaire
marseillais, c'était marqué dopage
obligatoire pour tout le monde et il est
arrivé, il a mis sauf pour Cantona.
C'est la légende qui court paraî que
c'est vrai. C'est vrai. Et voilà euh je
veux dire virant qu'on lui dit soit tu
prends ça et tuas un champion du vélo et
tu nourris ta famille à vie ou soit tu
prends pas ça et tu finis euh
mécanicien. Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
J'en sais rien moi. Tu vois ? Et
aujourd'hui les rythmes de si on parle
du foot de la FIFA, l'UEFA de nouveau
encore, je veux dire c'est le coréen
Sonne, il a joué je sais plus combien de
matchs, pas de vacances
pas de repos à Noël et les cadences sont
trop élevées. On joue trop souvent, trop
parce que en fait il faut vendre le
football. On je pour qu'on soit en
forme, il faudrait qu'on joue tous les
15 jours a priori, mais on peut pas tu
peux pas Neymar euh tu vois pas l'argent
que tu perdais perdrait si on diffusait
un match tous les 15 jours. Donc on fait
croire qu'on a besoin de rythme. Donc
euh mais Neymar, il va passer sa vie à
avoir mal quelque part. Il va prendre
antisouleur, douleur, puis des cachetons
et tout ce que tu veux pour jouer. On le
football ne prend pas notre santé en
compte. On veut qu'on joue, le show doit
continuer et puis
pas des jeux sur la santé de des joueurs
quoi.
Bah évidemment, ouais, la les cadences
sont trop élevées.
Euh que penses-t-il de la liberté
d'expression en France ? Bah c'était bah
là on peut prendre ce qu'a dit Ango par
exemple euh les il y a eu des quelques
polémiques comme ça moi aussi sur les
sur les les femmes de 50 ans, tu vois
des trucs comme ça. Euh ces gens-là ne
m'intéressent pas tu vois par exemple
euh ils existent pas. Et euh donc euh
euh
la liberté d'expression par exemple sur
le racisme.
Euh il y a il y a un film que que j'aime
bien, c'est Dear White People là, je
sais pas si tu connais ce truc. Euh
c'était euh les sur les les black face,
tu vois, et les black ont dit à un
moment bah nous on n'aime pas les black
face. Donc si on te dit qu'on aime pas
les black face, faut pas que tu fasses
des black face. Ah ouais mais nous ça
nous fait rire de faire des black face.
Non, c'est pas marrant. Donc tu les fais
pas. C'est un peu ça quoi. Si on te dit
à un moment ça faut pas le dire parce
que ça ne plaît pas. La liberté suration
c'est aussi ça quoi. Ça faut pas le dire
parce que c'est pas bien. Moi ça me gêne
ou c'est un problème faut peut-être plus
le dire.
Charlie [grognement]
bah il y a tu vois toute la société a
vachement changé. Michel Leb on a ri
il y a 30 ans. On a ri sur ces sketchs
où il faisaient l'africain. Je sais pas
si tu te souviens. Je sais pas si tu as
ris là-dessus. Tu te souviens pas. On
arrive quoi aujourd'hui c'est pas
possible. Donc il y a des il y a des
limites. Alors je crois que c'est des
proches qui disent "On peut rire de tout
mais pas avec n'importe qui." C'était
pas C'est lui hein je crois. Non. Euh
bah je suis Charlie évidemment. Je suis
évidemment Charlie et à vie. Euh ils
sont peut-être allés loin, j'en sais
rien. Il fallait peut-être arrêter un
moment parce qu'ils ont ils en sont
morts. Euh il faut qu'il continuent à
être libre. Dans une société idéale, on
pourrait dire plein de choses. On
pourrait euh être libre aussi de dire
plein de conneries évidemment, mais à un
moment, si ça te met en danger, si ça
crée des problèmes, ça faut peut-être
arrêter, faut mais en de faut peut-être
en parler, discuter pour les je veux
dire les les problèmes dans les stades,
la discussion elle est elle est hyper
importante, l'éducation. Mais oui, dans
une société dial, on devrait pouvoir
dire tout et faire tout, sauf le
racisme, sauf le sexisme, sauf
[rires] on pas dans la
que le racisme. Ah non, que rien sur les
Indiens. Alors là, Packpack tout ça là,
c'est quoi P
Pinis pakistanais, tu sais,
les mecs sur Twitter, ils mettent sale
Pac pack, va vendre des fleurs, tout ça.
Sunzu nous dit euh du moins la question
de Sunzu, sa vision du hasard en tant
que joueur de poker. Est-ce qu'il y a du
du hasard dans le poker ?
Bah la chance n'existe pas, tu vois. La
chance c'est un paramètre mathématique
qui est hyper qui est calculé, tu vois.
Il y a il y a des Je me souviens d'un
d'un joueur chez Tom Dur, je crois.
C'est un très très grand genre de poker
et qui tu sais euh euh c'est c'est la
métaagame, les algorithmes, les dans le
poker et euh et tu as des tu fais une
sorte d'équation avec tout plein de
paramètres que tu que tu et après tu
joues ton coup euh avec la position à la
table, les joueurs qui sont là, la main
que tu as, les le flop qui est tombé et
cetera et cetera et puis après tu joues
ton coup et tu tu peux perdre parce que
c'est un tirage de cartes. Sauf que s'il
a 50 virgues quelque chose, tu le joues
à l'infini, tu as gagné, ça veut dire
que tu as pris la bonne décision. La
chance, elle existe. Tu sais quand tu
fais un con flip, tu vois le pil ou
face, si tu le fais une fois sur deux à
vie, tu es sûr de de faire une fois sur
deux pile ou face. Sauf si tu es très
fort et tu es capable de lancer et que
le truc il tombe pile comme ça au
milieu, tu vois. Mais [__] j'ai
essayé, je me suis entraîné, tu vois, je
lancer le truc pour que le truc il tombe
pas à plat. Parce que s'il tombe à plat
à vie, tu es sûr de faire 5050. Sauf que
ma vie vérifie pas l'infini. Et donc si
j'ai deux as contre deux rois, je peux
perdre deux rois deux ases contre deux
rois toute ma vie. Et le le hasard, euh
je sais pas.
Les GIO à Paris, euh tu es pour ou tu es
contre ?
Euh, je suis contre, complètement
contre. Euh
je suis je suis contre alors le
président du CNOS SF, je sais plus
comment ça s'appelle. Alors je sais plus
comment il s'appelle, j'étais un un à
une un un je sais pas comment on appelle
ça, un colloc l'autre fois puis il a
pris la parole, il a dit euh euh
l'objectif c'est 100 médailles. Mais
comment ça peut être un objectif quoi ?
Alors l'objectif des Jo, c'est
d'organiser les J pour la population
pour ça peut pas être de gagner quoi. Et
et là tu vois bien que il y a l'objectif
il est pas le bon. Ça va être évidemment
la mairie de Paris, créer un événement
pour valoriser la ville de Paris pour
que les gens viennent trouvent cette
ville magnifique. Ils vont la nettoyer,
vont faire flamber l'immobilier, vont
plein plein de choses. Pas grand-chose
de social, évidemment pas. Pas grand
chose tourner vers la population. les
grandes compétitions à travers le monde,
souvent c'est des catastrophes euh ça
infastructure qu'on qu'on construit qui
ne servent plus à rien. J'ai croisé
aussi récemment le président de la
Fédération de l'athlétisme. Je lui dis
"Ah mais tu es encore là ?" Dit non mais
j'ai arrêté mais j'ai rempli ma mission.
On a on a eu 16 médailles au dernier.
Euh c'est ça peut pas être ça une la
mission de d'un organisme d'État euh qui
a une des objectifs de de d'intérêt
général. Je sais pas comment on appelle
ça.
Question. Euh peut-on être de gauche et
aimer le poker ?
J'ai arrêté le poker déjà. Euh je crois
qu'on enfin je suis de gauche quoi. Je
suis de gauche. Moi je suis pas au
pouvoir. Euh je serai au pouvoir
bientôt. Moi je vais finir perd dans la
République. Faut qu'il sache les gens.
Euh euh même si je le serai peut-être
pas. Euh bah oui, pourquoi pas ? Enfin,
j'étais footballeur et je suis de gauche
et je suis saurais toujours. Je vois
aucun aucune incompatibilité. Je suis
pour le système social français de
gauche avec moi je viens des allocations
familiales, de la sécurité sociale et
l'assurance chômage.
Je veux que ça continue. Euh j'ai
peut-être eu du talent, peut-être que
moi je me suis battu, je me suis
défoncé, peut-être que j'étais meilleur
que les autres, peut-être que je me suis
plus défoncé qu'un autre. Mais moi, si
je suis un jour footballeur, c'est parce
que je suis né en France
et que mon petit club de quartier, il
était subventionné.
Il y avait des bénévoles qui étaient là
parce que la pelouse, elle était euh
tendue, il y avait un éclairage qui
était payé par l'argent du contribuable
et cetera et cetera et cetera. Et ben ça
c'est la France. Et ben, je veux que ça
continue et je veux renvoyer
l'ascenseur. J'ai jamais oublié ça et
jamais je j'irai contre ça. Voilà,
est-ce que
j'existe grâce au système français.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à la communauté ?
Hm
mon livre comme ses pieds parce que je
trouve que c'est une belle histoire d'un
d'un petit gars de Cocilloville qui
qui euh qui arrive
en finale de Coupe du monde.
Euh
je fais je je vis aux Abesses un peu
chez les bobos et j'adore aller à
Barbess. Voilà, c'est ça ma vie quoi. Je
peux faire le trait d'union entre ces
gens. J'aime j'aime
Je suis pas un bobo, moi. Je suis vers
les classes populaires. Euh deuxème
livre euh
je crois que le
euh Ah [__] ! [__] j'aurais dû
préparer ça. Je savais que tu allais me
poser la question. Et ben non, il faut
pas préparer.
Il y a un livre qui m'a qui s'appelle
Kaawa, c'est euh qui est de Donald West
Lake et c'est le livre qui m'a euh qui
m'a fait aimer beaucoup lire et moi j'ai
pas lu beaucoup dans ma vie.
Ton premier bouquin, c'était à 20 ans ?
C'était à 20 ans ? Ouais. C'était la
Non, mon premier bouquin qui n'était pas
imposé à l'école, c'était la perle de
Steinbeck que j'ai lu. Céit un petit
livre qui a changé ma vie aussi. Oui,
d'une certaine manière. Et puis après,
j'ai lu un livre très important, c'était
un livre de Penac. Alors après, moi
[grognement] j'ai commencé à lire avec
euh les Penac, la petite marchande de
prose, la fait carabine et cetera. Puis
il avait il y avait un livre, un essai
sur le français et il disait euh euh "On
n'est pas obligé de finir un livre." Et
ça ça a été très très important pour
moi. Moi je viens d'un quartier. Un
jour, on était allé
au collège, on était allé au théâtre, on
était jamais allé au théâtre de notre
vie. et cette petite classe un peu
mélangée blanc, noir arabe indien, on
était là et ça dure 2h30 3h et un moment
la prof elle a dit euh euh ch et j'ai un
pote il lui a dit mais vous pouvez pas
nous dire chute madame on sait pas faire
ça nous on n jamais fait ça de notre vie
3h dans un théâtre c'était j'ai adoré
mon pote ce jour-là j'ai adoré et ben la
lecture c'était un peu pareil on nous a
pas appris c'était dur ma ma sœur on est
moi c'est une famille un peu avec des
cadres assez C'est dur et tout. On avait
pas le droit de sortir. On était hyper
Ma sœur, elle s'échappait pour aller
lire à la bibliothèque. Ma sœur, elle
est très cultivée. Elle a pris beaucoup.
C'est quoi son prénom ?
Vironie. Elle est elle est je suis épaté
ma famille. Comment mon père il est très
avec ma mère ? Ma mère ma mère elle
m'envoie des SMS. Elle fait jamais de
faute d'orthographe, jamais de faute de
conjugué gens. C'est incroyable. Elle
vient de Lille Maurice. Elle est elle a
arrêté assez tôt les études. Je la
trouve fantastique. Elle est arrivée en
France à 23 ans avec quatre enfants.
Quatre enfants. Tu imagines ce que c'est
avec son mari qui allait travailler à
l'usine. C'est une bonne femme
incroyable. Elle est fantastique.
C'est quoi son petit prénom ?
Elle s'appelle Tamayanti. C'est son vrai
prénom. Elle s'appelle Nalini et mon
père est mort. Il s'appelle Mouslaya.
Mouslaya. Il a travaillé très très dur
pour sa famille. C'est j'étais fier
quand j'ai quand j'étais à aux Jeux
Olympiques, quand j'ai fait les JO et
ils étaient là-bas. Je me suis dit
[__] c'est quelque chose quoi. C'est
quelque chose. Et tu m'as demandé un
autre truc.
Tris livres.
Trois livres. Le troisème
euh euh
un livre qui m'a marqué beaucoup.
Tu reviendras pour nous le conseiller.
Ouais. Et euh dernière question qui
n'est pas une question qui est laisser
un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable.
Euh vous avez euh votre vie entre entre
les C'est là c'est vraiment ça. Alors
juste c'est très le petit Squarburk là.
Quand on a gagné, on est allé voir le
maire, il y avait un gamin qui est pas
un gamin, il avait 21 ans. Il m'a dit
euh c'est le maire là ? J'ai dis ouais
c'est le maire. et il me dit "On a
gagné, il va rester le terrain." J'ai
dit "Oui, il va rester." Il m'a regardé
"Bah, on peut se battre, on peut y
aller. C'est à vous de le faire. C'est à
vous de le faire. C'est ils y étaient
pour la marche, pour le climat, pour
l'environnement. Il y avait beaucoup de
jeunes. C'est à vous de le faire. Nos
les générations d'avance se sont battues
pour nous. Nous peut-être qu'on l'a pas
fait, on a cru que c'était arrivé. Les
acquis sociaux et cetera. C'est à vous
de le faire. Vous pouvez le faire et on
vous accompagnera. Moi, je vais me
lancer dans la politique, c'est sûr et
certain, pour montrer que euh un
homme footballeur peut et la démocratie
a le droit, elle me permet de de faire
ça. Vous pouvez le faire, vous devez le
faire sinon on va en crever quoi.
Vic de rassau, merci.
Merci beaucoup à toi. C'était génial.
Coupé.